herzlich willkommen liebe zuschauerinnen
die wir zuschauer beim dritten und
letzten tag des afg bundes
parteitages im sächsischen riesa draußen
vor der halle brüllende hitze wie in
fast ganz deutschland hier eher
temperatur
temperierte atmosphäre das entspricht
auch der
atmosphäre bei der afg hier in riesa im
moment man hat ja versuchte den streit
und die zwistigkeiten hier in riesa und
zu beseitigen tino coop hat gestern
abend im zdf noch einmal gesagt wir
wollen die verschiedenen strömungen
zusammen führen zu einem kräftigen strom
da ist allerdings der begriff der
stromlinienförmigkeit dann auch nicht
weit heute geht es um inhaltliche fragen
um europa um waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine wir sind bis 12 uhr hier dabei
was bisher geschah vor allem gestern das
was in den kolleginnen und kollegen des
heute-journals noch einmal für uns
zusammen
es ist gute miene zu einem miesen
ergebnis tino keller ist wieder afg chef
mit dem schlechtesten ergebnis eines afd
vorsitzenden in der afg geschichte nur
knapp über 50% und nicht alleine wie er
lange wollte sondern mit alice weidl
neben ihm in der doppelspitze die auch
noch deutlich besser abschneidet der
neue alte chef redet sich das ergebnis
irgend wie schön
es ist der aufbruch der afc ist uns
gelungen in den neuen bundesvorstand
alle strömungen zu vereinen damit wir
gestärkt aus diesem bundesparteitag
herausgehen in einen strom hineingehen
der uns stärkt es ist weniger ein strom
der ihn stärkt als eine strömung die ihn
duldet der anführer der radikalen björn
hübner tritt zwar nicht selber an aber
drückt reihenweise seine leute durch
dieser neue bundesvorstand entspricht
bisher vollständig meinem geschmack es
ist der geschmack eines
rechtsextremisten einen vorstand von rcs
gladen der durchmarsch der radikalen
wird zum desaster der für ard
verhältnisse
gemäßigteren wer in seiner
bewerbungsrede sowas hier fordert
verliert
wir müssen aus dem tief indem wir sind
dringend raus kommen mit einer neuen
politischen kommunikation mit einem
neuen stil mit einem neuen wind dass die
wähler da draußen auch sehen ahadi afd
da tut sich was positives wir brauchen
auch eine charme offensive richtung
wähler weniger verbessert hat weniger
gehässigkeit doch gehässigkeit ist
gerade gefragt auf diesem parteitag das
hat alles weidl verstanden die in ihrer
rede gegen den ex-chef genüsslich
nachtritt und damit punktet jörg nolte
hat vor einer woche in einer groß
angekündigten pressekonferenz seinen
beitritt zur katholischen mini partei
zentrum erklärt
er hat dafür extra einen kostspieligen
saal in der bundespressekonferenz in
berlin gebucht und tatsächlich hätte für
dieses trauerspiel ein beichtstuhl in
einer friedhofskapelle
aufgereiht die er am alten wird heute
lückenlos ausradiert es ist der tag der
abrechnung die radikalen hatten rache
geschworen als morten 1 den rechtsextrem
andreas kalbitz aus der partei warf
keiner von denen die damals mit gestimmt
haben ist mehr dabei ist abgewählt oder
hingeschmissen nach einer wütenden
häutung ein lager endgültig im abseits
es tatsächlich so dass die ankündigung
von tino copala dass man alle strömungen
im bundesvorstand abbilden wollen die
ich erfreut zur kenntnis genommen hatte
in keiner weise umgesetzt ist wahlen
verloren mitglieder verloren personell
und inhaltlich ausgedünnt die iaaf die
in der krise sucht den neuanfang sucht
ihr heil im radikal
ja also das war bis gestern abend ein
parteivorstand ein bundesvorstand wir
bei der afg genau heißt ganz im sinne
des neuen gespanns ganz an der spitze
pofalla und alice bei uns ist jetzt
martin vinzens sie sind
landesvorsitzender von der fdp nordrhein
westfalen und auch fraktionsvorsitzender
der partei im landtag wieder ganz knapp
noch reingekommen ist ja auch der größte
landesverband hat glaube ich hier auch
die meisten delegierten haben sie es
gerade gehört dass eigentlich die
sogenannten gemäßigten in der partei
gestern irgendwie untergepflügt worden
sind wurde am gestrigen tag nicht nur
die er am neunten begraben sondern auch
der einfluss der westlichen
landesverbände in der afg einen schönen
und morgen erst mal
mache ich nicht gerne da direkt an der
stelle sprechen das sehe ich explizit
nicht so also die fdp nach den letzten
wahlergebnissen befindet sich natürlich
in einer krise das braucht man auch
nicht schönreden das ist das keine
immanent tötete aber es müssen eine wenn
man sie nicht behandeln würde und das
hat die mitgliedschaft natürlich in
unruhe versetzt wird es gab jetzt zwei
möglichkeiten entweder ein neues team
was vielleicht mit einem neuen impulsen
dann auch noch morgen oder aber die
kontinuität gestern hat man sich sehr
eindeutig für die kontinuität
entschieden und dann ja und das muss man
sagen dass es für einen auf dem
parteitag ja auch er vielleicht fast ein
bisschen ungewöhnlich hat man ja fast 10
copala in seinem team wünschen ja auch
so unterstützt also fast das gesamte
team was er sich vorgestellt hat also
stromlinienförmig stromlinienförmig will
ich nicht sagen aber eine eine
ungewohnte geschlossenheit ja dann doch
die hier präsentiert wurde nach dem kino
copa nebenbei viel unruhe in der
mitgliedschaft kann er vielleicht
schwachen ergebnis gewählt wurde für
abliefert ist auch nicht das ganz
untypisch dass man es knapp drüber
schafft aber vielleicht nicht das werk
lahm danach hat man ihm er sofort im
prinzip genau auf das zu geschehen
gespräche und hat den unterstützten sie
sind ja jetzt verantwortlich für die afg
politik in nordrhein westfalen das hätte
sie ja um ein haar die parlamentarische
existenz gekostet offenbar kommt die afg
im westen nicht gut an anders als in
thüringen wo sie und in sachsen musiker
stärkste partei bei der bundestagswahl
wurde in nrw der sich fast rausgeflogen
also es ist eigentlich keine partei nach
westlichem geschmack
neu ist auch das kann ich natürlich
nicht ganz so stehen lassen wir sind als
relativ junge partei immerhin im zweiten
wahl antritt zum zweiten mal in den
landtag eingezogen das ist ein novum in
der neuen republik dass eine so junge
partei ist tatsächlich direkt schafft
wir sind da natürlich recht erfolgs
verliebt gewesen ist es trotz zu bauen
das auch nicht schönreden es ist ein
warnschuss gewesen mit 5,4 wir haben es
ja sie haben es gerade schon treffend
beschrieben gerade noch mal in den
landtag schafft das macht aber auch
dieses spannungsfeld es hier aussieht
beobachten dass er hier seit geraumer
zeit der mit uns und verfolge auch immer
die übertragung dazu das ist schwierig
ist natürlich mit den östlichen
landesverbänden zu erzählen dass diese
politik in teilen vielleicht nicht mehr
ankommt wenn man dort kurz davor ist die
stärkste kraft zu werden und da dieses
dieses spiel heraus zu aufzulösen und
einen mittelweg zu finden damit einander
klarzukommen er auch in dieser dualität
das ist die aufgabe dafür den nächsten
bundesvorstand jetzt zwei winter
schwierigkeiten haben die westlichen
bedürfnisse hier noch unterzubringen es
ist ja so dass man hätte ja hier als
spiritus rektor und steuermann des
parteitags agiert er hat für kein amt
kandidiert er ist voller dynamik hat
eine klare strategie und er möchte
eigentlich die partei nach seinem
ebenbild verformen da haben aber
westliche
landesverbände und deren vorstellungen
nicht mehr so sehr viel platz auch in
dieser neuen struktur kommission die da
jetzt gebildet werden soll ich also
jeder jeder politisch aktive möchte
natürlich in der partei so wirken dass
es vielleicht auch seinen eigenen
persönlichen ansprüchen seiner eigenen
politischen vorstellungen entspricht das
ist ja ganz normal also auch eine partei
wie unsere mittlerweile noch über 1000
mitgliedern da gibt's ja sehr
unterschiedliche vorstellungen auf die
politik zu tun hat zu drücken wenn sie
sagen er war hier sehr präsent er ist
aus einem sehr kleinen landesverband
also seine 1
der entwurf hat und mit klaren
einschussmöglichkeiten soeben er über
die bühne er über die präsenz hier die
größere landesverbände bayern baden
württemberg nordrhein westfalen ich bin
heute mit wieder mit 100 delegierten
angereist ist ein fünftel der stimmen
wir könnten unsere stimme gewicht allein
durch unsere präsenz der delegierten
schon zum ausdrucken dafür aber genau
das werde stellung erwähnt sind passiert
ja nicht hat kleinen landesverband und
ist hier präsent nrw
stehen wir das nach wenig zu sagen mit
den meisten delegierten und auch
irgendwie spielt hier keine rolle auch
das sehe ich nicht so wir haben zwei
sehr gute kandidaten in den
bundesvorstand entsandt wir haben zum
einen an auch das sagt man uns ja häufig
jetzt nicht mehr nach dass wir die
professoren partei sind wir haben
liberalen wirtschaftsprofessor mit
professor hart weil in den
bundesvorstand eltern haben den
bundesvorsitzenden der jungen
alternative carlo clemens an meiner
landtagskollegen in den wohnungsbau
scheine ich glaube zwei sehr gute
kollegen aus nordrhein westfalen sind
jetzt auch teil des teams von team opa
früher noch in der letzten frage auf die
inhaltlichen diskussion eingehen es geht
heute auch wieder mal um europa beim
parteitag beim wahlparteitag in dresden
letztes jahr wurde beschlossen raus aus
der europäischen union raus aus dem euro
sowieso wenn man jetzt nicht mal den
konflikt mit russland ansieht der ja
wirklich gefährlich ist auch für
westeuropa zeigt sich doch der wert bei
aller kritik an der europäischen union
der wert einer gemeinsamen europäischen
linie eines gemeinsamen europäischen
einer gemeinsamen europäischen idee
wieso wollen sie ausgerechnet diese
schutzgemeinschaft verlassen im effekt
keine schutzgemeinschaft ist wenn sie
sich anschauen wie allein die
aktionspakete diskutiert werden dann
gibt es dort keine einstimmige mehrheit
dann sieht man genau da die schwächen
auf der europäischen union in ihrem
aufbau dass es dort eben keine
einstimmige lösung gibt es immer wieder
leute gibt die auch den europäischen die
europäische meinung da untergraben wir
sehen es jetzt auch in der
verteidigungspolitik es gibt eben nicht
diese europäische artikulierte
außenpolitik und nachdem wir ja im
letzten jahr beschlossen haben aus der
europäischen union auszutreten im
prinzip einen wechsel zu vollziehen
programmatisch was mir im übrigen
persönlich auch zu weit ging einer
derjenigen die sagen wir müssen daher
reformieren und anders mit den
europäischen regierungen aber wir haben
jetzt genau diesen punkt texte mit leben
gefüllt und wenn sie sich das anschauen
dann ist es ganz im gegenteil eher so
dass wir eher klar sagen dass wir für
ein europa sind dass wir für die
landeslisten in der gießerei was wir den
briten auch vorwerfen wir müssen an der
stelle jetzt weiter abbrechen denn der
parteitag hat begonnen soweit martin
vinzenz im phoenix-interview danke dass
du aber führen und ich gebe jetzt zu
todes müller der parteitag hat begonnen
vielen dank alexander kähler brücken
morgen auch von mir an dieser stelle zum
dritten tag des parteitages wir blicken
denn direkt in den saal denn da geht es
jetzt direkt um die frage wann über die
politischen themen hier geredet werden
soll er am nachmittag oder am vormittag
die debatte über diese frage läuft
gerade im premium und deswegen geben wir
zackig in die diskussion über diese
frage danke schön weiter im blauen saal
mikrofon
im blauen saal mikrofon
ja also ich bin dafür dass man hier mix
fährt wir können gerne den top 18
beratung und beschlussfassung über
änderungen an das schiedsgericht ordnung
vorziehen also heilt nach top 14 aber
unbedingt wenn alle noch aufmerksamkeit
sind aufmerksam sind den top 15 mit den
resolutionen hier
durchgehend weil wir müssen von diesem
parteitag neben einem personellen signal
auch natürlich ein politisches signal
senden und er kann jetzt um diese
uhrzeit auf ein mögliches früheres ende
des parteitages so dass alle hier
delegierten nach hause kommt kann
definitiv nicht schon gesprochen werden
also bitte heute ist ein arbeitstag und
heute machen wir verdammt noch mal auch
diese resolution in vielen dank im roten
saal mikrofon
im roten saal mikrofon bitte herr paul
ja also die resolution mit den
resolutionen hinterlassen wir einen
politischen
fingerabdruck oder fußabdruck und es ist
meines erachtens wichtig auch
insbesondere was unser schlüssel thema
einwanderung islam angeht ein signal zu
setzen und zwar dann wenn die presse
noch da ist und ich glaube das ist ein
schlüsselthema von daher würde ich da
den antrag eher ablehnen
jetzt weiter im blauen saal mikrofon ich
will mich dem antrag von frau dr alles
weidl anschließen die
satzungsänderungen vorne anzustellen es
ist prima vorgearbeitet worden es ist es
wirklich wichtig und es wäre auch schön
wenn wir dann für die resolution
wirklich viel zeit hätten und nicht
diskussionen aus grund von irgendwelchen
zeitdruck abwürgen müssen also wir haben
einfach eine viel and stress der haltung
da dazu jetzt weiter im roten saal
mikrofon ja vielen dank robert lambro
landessprecher hessen nicht unterstützte
den vorschlag von alice weidl diese
satzungsfragen sind sehr wichtig wir
haben ja eine politische resolution
schon verabschiedet zu einem zeitpunkt
als die presse auch noch zahlreich
vertreten war die sind jetzt fast alle
nicht mehr da werden wir jetzt
resolutionen machen das hätten wir am
ersten tag machen sollen die kriegt kaum
noch einer mit die satzungsfragen sind
dringend da
na ja das klingt jeder mit der uns hier
einschaltet vorhandene live wir in den
nächsten stunden dazu es ist genau
umgekehrt wir haben gestern ein
wunderbares personal politisches signal
gesendet dass von der presse aufgenommen
wurde und heute müssen wir einfach
politisches signal senden solange die
presse noch hier ist und ich bitte euch
für diesen satzung scrum interessiert
sich niemand außer wir selbst wenn wir
jetzt die saat der satzung priorität
geben dann ist das die fortsetzung des
selbst beschäftigungs modus setzen wir
auch in dieser frage ein zeichen und
stellen wir die sachpolitik voran ich
bitte darum
herr pofalla
gegenrede auch zu thomas ich gebe ja ein
stück weit recht natürlich brauchen wir
politisches signal dieses parteitags und
das soll auch nicht hinten runterfallen
im gegenteil aber wir haben hier
wirklich grad durch den ausfall der
letzten parteitage wichtige
satzungsänderung vorhaben das
schiedsgericht angeht die
beitragsordnung angeht etc das ist gut
und sehr gut sogar vorbereitet ich
musste albrecht glaser absolut recht
geben und ich unterstütze auch alice
reihen gehen hier als bundesvorstand
wollen diese dinge die gut vorbereitet
sind relativ schnell durchziehen und
dann kann man die politischen signale
auch setzen
dann haben wir einen geschäftsmann der
im roten sakko vor wir glaube ich eine
sekunde früher
ich denke wir haben alle argumente
gehört und ich fordere ende der debatte
ändere debatte beantragt gibt es eine
gegenrede
kann ich nicht sehen das ende der
debatte beschlossen und wir kommen hier
so abstimmung
so das heißt der bundesvorstand hat
heute gerade zu beginn des parteitages
vorgeschlagen dass ersterer interne
partei fragen debattiert und abgestimmt
wird bevor es zu den politischen themen
und diese option akku und genau darüber
entscheidet sich gerade der parteitag ob
er dem wie folgt oder auch nicht dann
den top 18 aufrufen befassen top 19
aufrufen befassen dann top 17 aufrufen
und befassen und dann weitermachen mit
top 15 16 20 21 22 wie gehabt in der
reihenfolge wer diesen vorschlag von dr
die zwei routine- copala folgen mag
bitte ich jetzt um die blaue stimmkarte
dankeschön gegenstimmen mit der roten
stimmkarte
enthaltungen
[Musik]
von meinem tisch aus sehe ich ehrlich
dafür gesehen damit ist der antrag
angenommen
dann verfahren wir so und ich hoffe dann
jetzt tobt ja für das heißt dass wir uns
in den nächsten zeiten über änderungen
an der bundessatzung änderungen an der
schiedsgerichtsordnung und änderung an
der finanz- und beitragsordnung
beschäftigen das heißt das werden wir
ihnen natürlich live zeigen
zeigen wie die partei über diese
internas diskutiert
mitgliederversammlung sein und an dieser
stelle schlagen wir ihnen wieder vor
beantragen eine redezeit begrenzung von
zwei minuten pro wortbeitrag für diesen
tagesordnungspunkt 14 in gänze aber nach
14 ergänzend es daheim seinen gegen
rhett partei wird sich jetzt erst mal
damit beschäftigen ob sie den nächsten
nicht der fall anregung von
mitgliederkarteien durch dazu gibt es
mehrere anträge und dieses ist der
nächste tagesordnungspunkt
jenem jetzt mit dem
tu9 und theo 10 sowie sn 17 da muss auch
ein ganz kurz geklärt werden inwieweit
die
sich
dass der antragsteller dort
hat die andere welt ein gewinde wir
haben mal ein geschäft oder anderen
blauen saal mikrofon bezogen ja ich sehe
ja antrag auf nichtbefassung mit diesen
antrag wir haben das thema mitglieder
parteitag schon oft genug
durchdiskutiert wir haben dann eine
mitgliederbefragung dazu gemacht wir
brauchen jetzt nicht noch mal unsere
zeit zu verschwenden wir haben wichtige
resolution und hier müssen wir unser
team nicht verdrängen also nicht
befassen mit diesem antrag nach kurzer
nachfrage also nicht verfassung mit den
drei anträgen theo 19 und essen 17
richtig benannt der antragsteller noch
mal kurz
so ist es da sind die drei anträge die
unter dem top 14 1 1 gereiht sind
so die gegen die gegenrede dazu liegt
zuallererst den wenn sie mögen den
antragstellern allerdings tatsächlich
bitte nicht in einer antragsbegründung
eingehen oder nur die zum
geschäftsführungs antrag warum das drauf
bleiben soll wäre dann sicherlich ihre
begründung wir beginnen am rednerpult ja
so wolff preis von oberspreewald lausitz
als antragsteller ist es gegen rhede
jeder kann sie anders ich glaube 2009 10
wurde ein mitgliederbegehren initiiert
und das ist haarscharf an der an dem
quorum vorbei gegangen dass der nächste
parteitag ein mitglieder parteitag
gewesen wäre wie er möchte mit diesen
antrag ganz einfach dieses verbriefen
dass der parteitag das entscheidet danke
gut das war die gegenrede vom
antragsteller kreis
oberspreewald-lausitz und ich glaube das
ist es in 17 ist auch ihrer nicht ja gut
dann haben wir die gegenrede gehört und
kommen zur abstimmung beantragt ist
nichtbefassung mit den anträgen unter
top 14 19 10 und 10 sowie der sn 17 wenn
sie diese anträge nicht befassen wollen
bitte jetzt in die blaue stimmkarte
dankeschön gegenprobe mit der roten
karte wenn sie die anträge befassen
wollen
enthaltungen dann ist die nicht
mitglieder schlossen die tage werden
also hier nicht befasst das war mal ein
instrument was die afg zu ihrer gründung
mit installiert hatte um sozusagen sich
anders zu positionieren als die
etablierten parteien
2020 gab es dazu einen
mitgliederentscheid der aber scheiterte
okay ganz kurz vor dem geschäft
kommt sofort eilmeldung
eilige durchsage der halter des
fahrzeugs mit dem amtlichen kennzeichen
wi en strich cr200 steht direkt vor der
halle und muss dann fahrzeug umgehend
entfernt wird sonst direkt gleich
abgeschleppt also
gwn wilhelm e mail nordpol samatha 200
bitte umgehend ihr auto
entfernen und wir haben einen
geschäftsumfang ampel in sein mikrofon
herr krieger mit christa cremer
nordrhein westfalen ich stelle den
antrag auf nichtbefassung weil das ist
eine angelegenheit eine in der baden
württembergische angelegenheit das
können die nächste woche auf dem
landesparteitag klären ich glaube da
sollten wir uns sicher einen
menschlichen und deswegen sollten was
hier mit nichtbefassung behandeln
danke schön dann
erhält auch hier vorzugsweise einen
vertreter der der anträge
das wort das wäre einmal her
spanien
ist am kreis geht um den antrag dass der
landesverband zentrum automobil von der
unvereinbarkeit licht liste der afd
wieder gestrichen werden soll dort steht
er seit herbst sein 21
vielen dank liebe freunde ich verstehe
diese interpretation die hier aufgefasst
wird dass es nur baden württemberg
betrifft es steht in der unvereinbarkeit
liste drin dass nur der landesverband
von zentrum automobil baden württemberg
betroffen sei das ist natürlich gar
nicht möglich weil zentrum automobilist
eine bundesweite organisation
und es gibt gar kein landesverband baden
württemberg von zentrum automobil und
deshalb ist dieser antrag an sich schon
sehr problematisch weil er ja gar nicht
greift abgesehen davon führte zu der
komischen situation dass jeder
landesverband veranstaltung mit zentrum
automobil durchführen kann und das auch
tut mit ausnahme des landesverbandes
baden württemberg der unsere größte
automobilindustrie hat das ganze ist an
sich ein sehr fragwürdiger vorgang und
ich bitte dass wir das hier als
bundesparteitag entscheiden es gibt auch
keine andere möglichkeit
wir haben wahrscheinlich momentan keinen
landesparteitag in baden württemberg wir
haben momentan eine kündigung der halle
und es ist unklar ob es einen solchen
landesparteitag geben wird und selbst
wenn es den landesparteitag baden
württemberg gäbe hätte der nicht die
autorität die unser ein paar kites
vereinbarung auf bundesebene zu kippen
und deshalb bitte ich darum dass heute
hier zu diskutieren
ja diese kleinst gewerkschaft steht in
verdacht zu rechtsextremen projekten
verbindung zu haben und deswegen wurde
sie vom bundesverband auf die
unvereinbarkeit liste gesetzt
nicht der fall wenn ich richtig sehe
dann kommen wir zur abstimmung gaben an
geschäften und eine gegenrede wenn sie
dem antrag auf nichtbefassung mit den
anträgen unter dem top 14 2 das ist
einmal antrag es in neun anderen zentrum
automobil von unvereinbarkeit liste
streichen sowie der es in zehn
gewerkschaft zentrum von der
unvereinbarkeit zur liste entfernen wenn
sie diese beiden anträge nicht befassen
wollen bitte jetzt die blaue stimmkarte
die gegenstimme mit der roten stimmkarte
wir meinen was gesehen zu haben würden
wir gern einmal elektronisch tränen dann
schauen wir auch gerät wurde auch noch
funktionieren
mit einem schnelle folie nur das heben
der stimmkarte hat keine eindeutige
mehrheit darüber
geben ob dieses thema behandelt werden
soll oder nicht genau darum geht es
jetzt es geht jetzt erst mal nicht darum
um das inhaltliche streiten oder das
inhaltliche diskutieren sondern
lediglich erstmal um die frage wird das
thema überhaupt behandelt oder eben
nicht
mit stimmen sie ab die frage wie halten
wir es mit dem landesverband zentrum
automobil und mit dieser gewerkschaft
zentrum automobil
so die abstimmung läuft jetzt das kennen
wir ja schon von sonos anderen beiden
tagen aus diesem parteitag in riesa
elektronische stimmkarte gezählt werden
373 delegierte das ist deutlich weniger
als in den tagen zuvor
gut das war doch recht deutlich
es gibt aber eine deutliche mehrheit da
nämlich mal einfach mit diesem thema und
hier nicht den parteitag befasst und
dann geht es weiter in der tagesordnung
finden wir die
aussprache hier drüber und zuerst erhält
dann der antragsteller das antrag des n9
in spanien und andere einmal das wort ja
dr spanien
ist unterwegs
und danach kann sich auch gleich schon
mal ein so da ist mir jetzt ein kleiner
fehler unterlaufen während ich
recherchiert habe natürlich wird jetzt
über dieses thema geredet
denn der parteitag hat dies so
entschieden und
sie haben davor ja wir haben eine
unvereinbarkeit liste ich weiß darüber
gibt es unterschiedliche meinungen wir
diskutieren ja generell auch nicht die
unvereinbarkeit liste aber ich habe mir
die unvereinbarkeit zwiste mehrfach
angesehen und wir haben auf der
unvereinbarkeit liste fast
ausschließlich oder ausschließlich
organisationen die vom verfassungsschutz
beobachtet werden organisationen die vom
verfassungsschutz verboten sind oder
organisationen die mit personen
kontaminiert sind die in rechtsextremen
also auch vom verfassungsschutz
verbotenen klar eingestuft sind keines
dieser kriterien keines dieser
objektiven kriterien trifft für den
zahlen es keine gewerkschaft die
arbeitnehmervertretung zentrum automobil
zu und aus diesem grund und aus diesem
grund allein schon aus diesem formalen
grund müsste man das lassen ich aber
sage aber noch mehr dazu zentrum
automobil ist die einzige
arbeitnehmervertretung im
gesundheitswesen das ist übrigens nicht
nur automobile es ist auch gesundheit
die einzige vertretung im gesundheits
und im automobilsektor
arbeitnehmervertretung die auch nur mit
uns redet wie glauben wir denn in die
betriebe reinkommen zu können ohne eine
arbeitnehmervertretung die für uns die
themen transportiert das ist das ist
genau das was ich gestern in sehr vielen
vorstands reden gehört habe dass wir die
vorfeldorganisationen
stärken wollen und dass sie mit denen
zusammenarbeiten wollen die nicht
kontaminiert sind und die nicht vom
verfassungsschutz verboten oder
beobachtet werden und dann erwarte ich
hier auch dass dieser parteitag dieser
linie folgt viele vorstandsmitglieder
sind gestern gewählt worden weil sie
gesagt haben sie wollen hier mit vorfeld
organisationen zusammenzuarbeiten und
hier haben wir genau den antrag der das
hier ermöglicht wenn die delegierten das
wollen dann bin ich dafür dass wir hier
genau das klima heute hier abräumen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
vielen dank dann ein vertreter des
kreisvorstandes münchen-nord der den
antrag erst in zehn begründen möchte ist
gibt es da jemanden
das ist anscheinend nicht der fall dann
eröffnen wir die aussprache dann geht es
zuerst los am blauen wunder in rot dann
hier vorne
am blauen koffer und bitteschön frau
besorgt ich bitte darum diese
unvereinbarkeit
aufzuheben und begründet es wie folgt
es ist hat wahrscheinlich ein eher
persönlichen touch aber ich kann sie
alle beruhigen frau weigel hat sich mit
herrn andreas ziegler abbilden lassen
und so groß darf da die aufregung nicht
sein wer sich als unsere
bundesvorsitzende mit dem prominentesten
vertreter abbilden lässt der kann in der
sache wahrscheinlich kein problem haben
sollten wir tatsächlich einzelne leute
nicht akzeptieren können dann ist das
gerechter eine einzelne person auch
diesbezüglich anzusprechen und zu
qualifizieren wir können uns nicht
permanent überall nur noch distanzieren
weil man uns irgend einen brocken
hinwirft es muss inhaltlich sachlich
begründet sein dankeschön
dankeschön machen weiter am boden sein
mikrofon
ich glaube dass wir als afd
vorfeldorganisationen brauchen dazu
gehören sicherlich auch so lange es
gewerkschaften wie verdi und co gibt
alternativen aber wir haben hier mit
blick auf baden württemberg und darum
wäre es schön gewesen wenn wir uns auch
die möglichkeit gibt dass in baden
württemberg zu diskutieren eine
sondersituation solange die vertreter
des zentrums in baden württemberg
veranstaltungen wie 20 21 mit npd und
dritten weg machen wollen wir als
baden-württembergische landespartei im
moment keine kooperation de haben
hausaufgaben zu machen und ich glaube
dass das die richtige position in dieser
frage ist nochmal petitum starkes ja
aber bitte dann auch nicht mit anderen
parteien sondern mit der afg
danke schön euer diese gewerkschaft hat
ein mitglied des der ex mitglied einer
neonazi band ist und weitere
rechtsradikale mitglieder im vorstand
sein sollen nach recherchen von
journalisten
es ist ja alles richtig dass wir
vorfeldorganisation brauchen aber wenn
vorfeldorganisationen wm hier in ihrem
vorstand leute drin haben die allem
anschein nach über mehr als nur kennt
verhältnisse tief in die echte rechte
extremistische szene hinein verfügen
dann ist das harakiri
stellt stellt euch doch nur mal nach der
gestrigen vorstandswahl
egal wie wild worden wäre es wäre
natürlich wieder einen seite rechts hoch
gewesen und als nächste genannt als
nächste maßnahme heben wir streichen wir
eine solche organisation aus der
unvereinbarkeit liste also man kann
seinem gegner auch sehr sehr einfach
machen und die munition frei haus
liefern die haben es in der hand
von der liste zu kommen die brauchen die
toxischen personen das ihrem vorstand zu
entfernen und schon ist alles in ordnung
bitte ablehnen
dann machen wir weiter blind sein
mikrofon so also wenn ich das jetzt
richtig verstehe wir distanzieren uns
von
rechtsextremisten das ist ja gut und
richtig aber jetzt sollten wir uns auch
von denen distanzieren die sich nicht
von rechtsextremisten distanzieren
ich warte jetzt auf das trotzdem nicht
von denen distanzieren sie sich nicht
von den distanzieren sie es nicht von
rechtsextremisten distanzieren
das ist das ist genau die logik des
verfassungsschutzes damit wollen wir uns
klein halten und da müssen wir genau das
richtige maß finden zwischen offensive
und defensive
natürlich muss so eine organisation wie
die npd auf ton vereinbart liste steht
aber bitte nicht zentrum automobil denn
wir klagen darüber dass die
arbeiterschaft dass die gewerkschaft
eine links sind wir stellen fest dass
die arbeiter einer unserer größten
wählergruppe sind und dass wir aber
nicht richtig durch brechen weil alle
gewerkschaften links ticken und nicht
bloß sprechen und da kommt jetzt eine
gewerkschaft auf und macht sich einen
armen und vertritt die arbeiterschaft
und ist offen für uns und dann haben wir
nichts besseres zu tun als uns vor
dieser gewerkschaft zu distanzieren ich
bitte euch mit politischer vernunft an
dann haben wir einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag
perplex
ja meine damen und herren jetzt haben
wir für und gegen gehört dass ich glaube
es ist eine ganz klare meinung hier im
saal die jetzt gleich abgestimmt wird
wir können uns da geht's weitere reden
glaube ich sparen und vorangehen jetzt
abstimmen deshalb stellt den
geschäftsordnungsantrag auf ende der
debatte und sofortige abstimmung
endet hier fertig wird vorne eine
gegenregierung
gegenrede es gibt hier noch wichtige
fakten die die mitglieder die
delegierten hier noch nicht kennen und
die müssen unbedingt vorgetragen werden
bevor jetzt über so eine wichtige frage
schnell schnell eine abstimmung
getroffen wird und die habe ich hier
auch vorbereitet dankeschön dankeschön
dann haben wir einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag auf ende der
debatte eine gegenrede gehört wer den
geschäftsordnungsantrag zustimmen möchte
bitte jetzt um die blaue stimmkarte
eine debatte gegenstimmen mit der roten
stimmkarte
enthaltungen dann ist das abgelehnt und
wir fahren und der debatte fort und vom
roten saal mikrofon drachen bei den
nächsten geschäftsordnungsantrag aber
noch im blauen wand von bevor wieder
bitteschön ja ich fordere ende der
rednerliste ich denke dass am abarbeiten
dieser rednerliste tatsächlich alles
muss ich kurz unterbrechen den dürfen
sie nicht stellen sie haben schon
gesprochen zum thema
da hinten ja ok übernimmt dort jemand
bitte schön ja ich übernehme diesen
geschäftsordnungsantrag ende der
rednerliste ist beantragt gibt es dazu
eine gegenrede
formal höre ich innerlich gegenrede
nicht der fall dann kommen zur
abstimmung werde die rednerliste
schließen möchte ich jetzt um das
handzeichen
gegenstimme
enthaltung dann ist die rednerliste
geschlossenen einmal kurz feststellen
aber die letzte person auf jeder
weiteren geräten was einmal die hand
heben bitte wir haben es ja monitore
halbwegs zu sehen
so
ok wer das damals dass es damals im
herbst 21 diese rechtsradikale
betriebsgruppe zentrum automobil auf die
unvereinbarkeit liste gekommen ist ist
laut recherchen von journalisten auf
betreiben von alice weidl im
bundesvorstand so beschlossen worden
und die unfälle hat es liste der partei
die regelt welche extremistischen
organisationen afd mitglieder nicht
angehören dürfen dort auf der karton auf
der blauen seite muss ich mal schauen
wer es da der letzte
haben wir
dort ist persönlich und passt auf dass
alles seine richtigkeit hat dann
fahren wir fort am roten saal mikrofon
bitte danke herr versammlungsleiter
liebe freunde dieser antrag
betrifft nur den landesverband baden
württemberg da steht sowieso ein
landesparteitag vor der tür dann soll
doch bitte der landesverband baden
württemberg uns helfen ein votum dazu
fällen und dann können wir es hier auf
dem bundesparteitag
bestätigen aber bis dahin sollten wir
doch baden württemberg die gelegenheit
geben das selbst zu klären und wir
hörten ja es gibt keine halle wir
niedersachsen hatten gerade ganz tolles
zelt für unseren parteitag ich schnell
da gern einen kontakt her
vielen dank wir haben ja noch darüber
sehen dass hinter den jungen die auf
frau baum die werbung im windschatten
hier
auch noch mit auf der liste was ich auch
noch vor beschlussfassung hier vorne
sodann habe ich jetzt als nächstes hier
vorne herrnhütte
also kurz zur transparenz ich mache
immer blau rot rednerpult und dann in
der reihenfolge war vorhin jungen hier
bitteschön ja sehr geehrte
versammlungsleitung sehr geehrter
bundesvorstand liebe freunde in riesa
schönen guten morgen auch von meiner
seite
[Applaus]
ich bitte euch
fangen wir endlich an politisch zu
denken und den selbst beschäftigungs
modus zu überwinden und ich leite meine
kurze ansprache ja ein mit der
deutlichen ansage an den sogenannten
verfassungsschutz dieser sogenannte
verfassungsschutz ist eine konzeption
die es in einem demokratischen
rechtsstaat nicht geben darf
ein inlandsgeheimdienst
ein inlandsgeheimdienst liebe freunde
als regierungsbehörde organisiert der
opposition beobachtet unterwandert und
versetzt ist weder mit dem demokratie
noch mit dem rechtsstaatsprinzip
vereinbar
[Applaus]
wir stehen gegenpartei karten und ein
machtinstrument und der so genannte
verfassungsschutz ist teil dieses
machtinstrument dass unser deutschland
abwickeln will wir müssen endlich das
bewusstsein in uns wachrütteln
beziehungsweise noch stärker werden
lassen dass wir eine dissidente partei
sind dass wir die einzig wahre
opposition die letzte position in diesem
lande sind
und deswegen
deswegen bestimmen wir qua unserer
eigenen kraft unseres eigenen
selbstbewusstseins unseres eigenen
willens wer extremistisch und von wem
wir uns abgrenzen
das macht hier eine regierungsbehörde
für uns und deswegen ist das keine
kategorie die wir anerkennen sollen
schlussbemerkung
politische hegemonie liebe freunde jeder
der sich mit politik theorie beschäftigt
hat weiß das fußt auf kultureller
hegemonie die kulturelle hegemonie
werden wir niemals nur mit dem
parlamentarischen weg erreichen wir
brauchen das vorfeld deswegen sage ich
ja zu den freien medien ich sage ja zu
den bürgern ich sage ja zu den
bürgerbewegung ich sage ja zum zentrum
automobiler wir brauchen dieses vorfeld
ohne dieses vorfeld sind wir nichts und
werde nicht durchbrechen also bitte
kommen mit dem weg von der heimat ist er
mit dem centro sie
ja ein weiteres mal dass ein
parteitag seinen stempel in der frage
wie rechtsradikal soll die
zusammenarbeit zwischen der partei und
18 organisationen ngo in diesem stück um
sein die unvereinbarkeit liste des
bundes missbraucht um hier in baden
württemberg thema zu spielen und wir
können das in baden württemberg regeln
aber nicht wenn der bund von oben im
prinzip uns das thema schon weg nimmt
deswegen sage ich weg von der
unvereinbarkeit liste und auf dem
letzten landesparteitag kann die frau
tochter weiter der herr martin hess und
der jungen gerne hier mitdiskutieren auf
dem parteitag des landes und da kann man
nicht einfach die karten spielen dass
ein landesverband baden württemberg des
centrum automobil sehen es offiziell gar
nicht gibt einfach auf die bundesebene
erhöht und hier es braucht dieser
unverfallbarkeit liste erstellt es kann
nicht sein dass baden württemberg regel
die probleme selber aber wir wollen sie
dann auch unter uns regeln
dann machen wir weiter am roten war nico
von
parteifreunden ich will vorausschicken
dass ich niemanden der handelnden
personen
dieses zentrums für automodelle
automobilindustrie persönlich kenne kann
also auch nichts zu den inhalten sagen
will nur den hinweis geben in bezug auf
diese vereinigung wird auch in anträgen
von einer gewerkschaft gesprochen da
will ich nur dazu sagen dass das hier
mit hundertprozentiger sicherheit keine
gewerkschaft ist und keine gewerkschaft
sein kann warum
bereits im jahr 2006
gab es auseinandersetzungen zwischen dgb
gewerkschaften und christlichen
gewerkschaften was die
anspruchsvoraussetzungen an eine
gewerkschaftliche organisation sind und
diese anspruchsvoraussetzungen an eine
gewerkschaftliche organisation sind klar
und deutlich definiert
hinsichtlich von satzungen von
organisatorischen aufbau von
aufgabenbereichen die dort beackert
werden und natürlich auch zur
personellen ausstattung also lange rede
kurzer sinn ich
will mich jetzt in diesen streit intern
nicht einmischen nur den hinweis geben
dass man bitte in dieser
auseinandersetzung nicht von
gewerkschaften redet weil es ansonsten
sein kann dass es organisation in diesem
lande gibt die genau hingucken wer sich
eigentlich gewerkschaft nennt und in
wahrheit gar keine gewerkschaft ist
schön dank
dann machen wir vorne weiter mit herrn
jungen
ja liebe freunde liebe parteimitglieder
ist es hier von politisch denken
gesprochen worden wir sollten anfangen
politisch zu denken
leider habe ich das jetzt in dem
wortbeitrag
entsprechenden nicht so richtig
vernommen ich will mal die realpolitik
hier ins spiel bringen wir müssen uns im
klaren sein mit wem wir es hier zu tun
haben es wird die ganze zeit gesagt und
so getan als würden wir ohne diese
vorfeldorganisation zentrum automobil
quasi unsere politische schlagkraft
verlieren ich möchte mal klar machen das
ist ein kleiner verein das ist eine mini
gewerkschaft die überhaupt was überhaupt
fraglich ist ob sie als gewerkschaft
bezeichnen kann so fängt das mal an das
heißt wir begeben uns hier in eine
verbindung und machen uns abhängig von
einer kleinen gruppe über die wir gar
keine kontrolle haben wo uns alles was
dort geschieht dann als afd in die
schuhe geschoben wird und das haben wir
nicht nötig und ich sage euch jetzt was
dort in die schuhe geschoben werden kann
oliver hilburger der chef hier
funktionär dieser gewerkschaft war
mitglied in der rechtsrock band neue
werte die zusammen auf dem gleichen
label
veröffentlicht wie die blood and honour
organisation eine mehr oder weniger
terror organisation liedtitel oder
liedtexte deutschland den deutschen so
soll es sein last keine fremdlinge mehr
rein in unserer land in unsere blogs
kommt kein gesocks zitat ende und so
geht es hier weiter daher wurde ein vom
arbeitsgericht als arbeitsrichter
abgesetzt weil sich seine band gegen die
verfassung gestellt hat und wir wollen
uns allen ernstes hier in verbindung
gegeben mit solchen leuten die jetzt
auch noch mit npd neue werte und so
weiter auf die straße gehen wir sind
doch die große starke afd wir haben das
doch nicht nötig liebe freunde machen
wir doch nicht so einen unsinn
und das ist ein thema von
bundespolitischer relevanz wir müssen
das hier auf dem bundesparteitag klären
das finde ich richtig dass wir uns hier
darüber aussprechen aber seien wir
selbstbewusst sehen wir uns nicht in
eine solche gesellschaft die uns schadet
und wer das fordert der betreibt das
geschäft des verfassungsschutzes war
genau da wollen sie uns haben liebe
freunde
[Applaus]
so wir machen weiter am blauen saal
mikrofon
jürgen stein kv mittelsachsen
unvereinbarkeit liste gibt es aus guten
grund
viele vereine organisationen und
parteien stehen auf aus gutem grund auf
dazu gehört nicht zentrum automobil wir
sollten aufpassen dass wir uns nicht zu
weit distanzieren einige vorredner haben
das bereits angebracht wir gehen ja
mittlerweile so weit dass sich von djk
distanziert wird wir brauchen uns nicht
wundern wenn man demnächst immer weniger
wahlhelfer haben weil wir
hyperventilieren distanzieren unnötig
und ein boot noch an den vorstand
überlegt bitte mal ob es nicht sinn
macht eine zeit einzuführen dass man
nach fünf jahren wenn man mal in der
jugend oder in seiner zeit einen fehler
gemacht hat und auf der unfehlbarkeit
unvereinbarkeit liste gelandet ist dass
man da nicht mal ein führt nach fünf
jahren nach zehn jahren muss schluss
sein so gewinnen wir wieder neue
mitglieder und das wo ist das je sein
dann haben wir einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag am roten sein
mikrofon richtig ist noch aktuell
er hat ihn zurückgezogen ist
zurückgezogen da machen wir mit der
diskussion weiter im roten saal mikrofon
gut vielen dank vielleicht sollten wir
die emotionen mal ein bisschen runter
kochen lassen fakt ist doch 1 im
vorletzten konvent wollte der konvent
also die mehrheit vom landesverband
entscheiden sollten mitglieder das ganze
unternehmen das ist der fakt es wurde
nicht getan weil angst wegen den wahlen
war gut vielleicht hätte man es machen
sollen das ergebnis wäre besser gewesen
weil die leute sagen die distanzieren
sich mal die zeigen klare kante
und lassen dieses zentrum wie dazu bei
fakt ist doch eins was heraus gesagt hat
noch jungen mag richtig sein dass da die
spitze das problem ist aber wie
diskreditieren ja alle mitglieder von
diesem verein und das darf einfach nicht
sein jedes mitglied dieses vereins wird
damit gleichzeitig als rechtsextrem oder
in verfassungsfeindlich dargestellt und
dann machen wir das gleiche was die
medien und andere mit uns machen das
geht nicht
deswegen
deswegen sollten wir diese liste von
also zentren automobil von der liste
streichen aber einen kooperations und
auftrittsverbot mit der spitze dieser
vereinigung machen das wäre fair das
wäre rechtmäßig das wäre anständig war
mit rechtsextremen möchten wir zumindest
ich und ich hoffe die meisten ja auch
nichts zu tun haben weder innerhalb der
partei nach außerhalb der partei weil
wir sind ein rechtsstaat partei für
freiheit da und deswegen runternehmen
von der liste kooperationsverbot das
wäre das beste vielen dank
danke schön dann machen wir weiter am
rednerpult vorbei
liebe freunde wir müssen aufhören und
von der presse und vom vsv uns her
treiben zu lassen das kann nicht sein
dass die bestimmen werte uns als
rechtsextrem gilt
und die arbeitnehmer gewerkschaft sind
vom automobil der spanien hat schon
gesagt hat sich ausgeweitet auf die
gesundheitsberufe ich als jetzt mitglied
im gesundheitsausschuss ihr könnt euch
nicht vorstellen wie viele anrufe ich
bekomme wie viel milch hilfe suchen der
mitarbeiter die nicht wissen wo sie sich
hinwenden sollen weil sie eben jetzt vor
der impfpflicht stehen weil sie vor der
vernichtung ihrer existenz ihrer
beruflichen stehen und ich habe sie
immer wieder dann an dieses zentrum
automobil verwiesen und die waren
glücklich und dankbar wie bedeutet die
menschen die brauchen unterstützung die
brauchen hilfe und jeder der dazu
beitragen kann der sollte von uns gehört
die stadt unterstützt werden dankeschön
haben wir einen geschäftsordnungsantrag
am blauen saal mikrofon bestimmt jetzt
hat er eben herr dr jung die chance
gehabt noch mal inhaltlich was dazu
beizutragen warum meine seine bedenken
gegen feinen seine phil schiller da
keine bedenken gegen gegen die anderen
form mit den stars sogar an selber
stelle ich den geschäftsordnungsantrag
nochmal auf ende der debatte und
abstimmung ich glaube es ist jetzt
hinreichend wirklich dargelegt worden
und lassen sie uns doch einfach jetzt
abstimmung und weiter machen die da hat
sich doch eine meinung gebildet
gegenrede ebenfalls am blauen war
mikrofon also liebe parteifreunde es
geht um eine ganz zentrale frage nämlich
wofür steht die afd was ist uns unsere
werte basiswert und wie verteidigen wir
transportieren wir unsere werte nach
außen und eine solche wichtige
diskussion die wirkt man nicht ab
sondern die muss man als afd führen auch
wenn sie für den ein oder anderen
schmerzlich sein mag und deshalb bitte
ablehnung dieses geschäftsordnungsantrag
dankeschön haben wir einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag auf ende der
debatte
dieser antrag über die frage beendet
wird die debatte ja oder nein
zur erklärung das zentrum automobil ist
ein eingetragener verein und bezeichnet
sich selbst als gewerkschaft für
angestellte der autoindustrie wurde 2009
gegründet von oliver halmburger es war
ein ehemaliges mitglied der rechtsrock
band neue werte der auch vorsitzender
dieses vereins ist es politisch rechts
einzuordnen und als eingetragener verein
organisiert der thüringische
verfassungsschutz warnte übrigens vor
der gewerkschaft ein aufgrund von
rechtsextremen und nicht mehr auf dem
boden dieser verfassung stehenden
aktionen
noch nicht wird die folie auch
einzublenden wir machen und 30 sekunden
ab dem augenblick jetzt ist die folie da
30 sekunden jetzt
derjenige der den antrag eingebracht
hatte dieses von der unvereinbarkeit
liste zu streichen weil jürgens jörg
spaniel ebenfalls vom landesverband
baden württemberg und sie haben gesehen
wie ein hacker spricht sich ebenfalls
dafür aus diesen verein von der
unvereinbarkeit liste zu streichen das
hatte er der bundesvorstand im herbst 21
entschieden
1 und dann ist die abstimmung beeendet
ende der debatte ist beschlossen kurzer
zwischenstand von der akkreditierung an
dieser stelle 10 uhr 41 sind 470
stimmberechtigte teilnehmer hier
akkreditiert
dann kommen wir zur abstimmung über die
über die anträge essent 9 und essent 10
so einen augenblick bitte
[Musik]
ja dahinter verbergen sich die sache
anträge eben den landesverband sowohl
als auch diesen verein gewerkschaft
automobil der eng gekoppelt ist an
diesem verein zentrum automobil von der
unvereinbarkeit liste zu streichen
abstimmung läuft wie immer elektronisch
wir warten auf das ergebnis wird es
spannend sein wie weit sich die partei
von dieser dann doch vom
verfassungsschutz beobachteten und als
nicht mehr auf dem boden dieser
verfassung stehenden organisation
distanziert oder ob sie sagt nein das
brauchen wir nicht mehr wir wollen
kooperationen und wir wollen nicht dass
dies noch auf der unvereinbarkeit liste
steht
so jetzt gerade noch eine frage
aufgetaucht mit einigen die geduld
interessant wird sein ob die röcke der
sich ja dafür ausgesprochen hatte ob
dieser antrag geben oder beziehungsweise
dass diese unvereinbarkeit wieder
gestrichen wird sich hier auf dem
parteitag erneut durchsetzt oder auch
nicht
das werden wir in wenigen augenblicken
sehen es gab ja eindeutig keine
abschluss stimmen aus dem bundesvorstand
dieses eben weiter zu belassen bei ab
der bundesvorstand der neu
zusammengesetzte
sich mal dafür und mal dagegen
ausgesprochen hat so kommen sie gar
nicht gerne ans mikrofon geben sie mir
kurz klären dankeschön
eine kleine randnotiz als es damals im
herbst 21 im bundesvorstand zu dieser
entscheidung kam war übrigens der
bundessprecher york leuten derjenige der
sich bei dieser abstimmung laut
recherchen der journalistin enthalten
hatte
damit ist gleich zu beginn des
parteitages dieses thema wohl im fokus
und im zentrum auch der delegierten die
jetzt zu beginn der debatte
beziehungsweise zu beginn des
parteitages noch von 326 inzwischen auf
430 hochgeschnellt sind
und sich dieser frage eben bemüßigt
haben weil die vorherige abstimmung mit
der es darum ging ob das überhaupt
behandelt werden soll oder nicht wo die
ja mit der frage beantwortet nein das
wollen wir und diese debatte ist jetzt
aufgrund eines geo antrags beendet
worden weil der parteitag gesagt hat die
themen sind von den gründungen her
endlich mit allen argumenten befasst wir
brauchen nicht weitere argumente
auszutauschen und das ist meine damen
und herren gibt es jetzt ein ende dieser
debatte und der erwartung die abstimmung
über die dann wohl doch wichtige frage
für die zukunft der afg
vor dem beschluss der landesverband
baden württemberg vom zentrum automobil
wird von der unvereinbarkeit 60
gestrichen so das ist das eine danach
gibt es einen teil den wir für
nicht zulässig halte und zwar für recht
evident weil hier beschlossen ist
beschlossen werden soll die mit in die
autonomie die satzung autonomie die
organisations ordnung rief von
landesverbänden eingriffen mit einem
einfachen parteitagsbeschluss und nicht
mit satzung da heißt es nämlich
gleichzeitig wird beschlossen dass
landesverbände der afd weder
kooperationsverbotes beratung und
vereinbarkeit beschlossene bundesweiten
organisation aussprechen können etwaige
beschlüsse sind vom bundesvorstand zu
bestätigen oder verlieren gültigkeit das
ist eine sache das kann man in einer
satzung sicherlich wären einfach so aus
der hand heraus und einem einfachen
parteitagsbeschluss ist das
wird überhaupt einen evident
parteien rechtswidrig das muss in die
satzung ein wir haben mindestens
satzungswidrig weil wir dort eine
autobahn die autonomie organisations
autonomie für landesverbände haben jetzt
könnte natürlich antrag schon etwas kurz
zurückziehen den teil würden aber auch
ansonsten ihnen nicht zur abstimmung
vorlegen herr spanien direkt kurz ich
hab kann das jetzt elektronisch gerade
auf die schnelle nicht vorbereiten ich
würde den antrag das separat abstimmen
lassen unter satzung können den aus dem
ersten teil raus nehmen aber es ist ja
wohl klar dass ein kooperationsverbot
das vom bund verordnet wird für eine
bundesweite organisation nicht für ein
landesvater dass wir hier eigentlich
musste abbrechen die eigene debatte ist
tatsächlich geschossen nur zu der frage
ob unternehmen oder nicht die fall
stellen als satzungs antrag hätte hätte
es gestellt sein müssen explizit mit
einem beschluss zeigt dass er heute hier
auch so nicht mehr die frage ist ob sie
ihren antrag hat entsprechend
kurzen aus den teilen aus dem antrag
rausnehmen weil wir würden ihn sowieso
nicht ab schon das aber es natürlich
schöner wenn sie es einfach zurückziehen
ja genau das möchte ich hiermit
ankündigt würde diesen zweiten teil
unternehmen begonnen damit ist das thema
für mich erledigt vielen dank dann
besteht anteil nur noch aus der antrag
nur noch auf dem ersten satz
landesverband baden württemberg von
zentrum automotive unvereinbarkeit liste
gestrichen sodann gibt es den antrag es
entziehen der die gewerkschafts zentrum
früher zentrum automobil von der
unvereinbarkeit
entfernen möchte und gänze nicht und den
landesverband der ist weitergehend den
stimmen wird daher zuerst also snc erst
wenn der angenommen ist ist da ja auch
der landesverband von umfasst
und ansonsten würde wenn der nicht
angenommen wird dann dem essen neuen
rohstoffen
das hängt damit zusammen dass ein
landesverband baden württemberg von
zentrum automobil eben in dieser region
sehr aktiv ist
es wird aber jetzt erst mal über den
weitergehenden antrag sowie julian fleig
das erzählt hat abgestimmt denn da heißt
es dass der bundesparteitag beschließt
die komplette gewerkschaft zentrum die
sich so nennt früher zentrum automobil
das war der frühere name von der
unvereinbarkeit liste entfernen soll
das betrifft dann alle bundesweiten
gegebenenfalls kleinen organisationen
die sich noch in den anderen
bundesländern befinden
sofia ist
da haben es nochmal eingewendet dass sie
wissen wo wir abstellen aber der ist ja
auch so wir im antrags buch steht also
sn 10 wird jetzt zuerst abgestimmt
machte es n9 dort mode erste wenn der s
10 angenommen ist hat sich der neun
automatisch auch erledigt amtes
abstimmung wer den code bzw war noch
einen verfahrens antrag auf abstimmung
mit den stimmen geräte nicht ob herr
lohse war das einmal ein mikrofon das
wollen wir nicht vergessen ja eigentlich
hieß es schon es sei elektronisch ab
beschlossen aber anscheinend weder
verwirrungen deswegen stelle ich ein
antrag das elektronische abzustimmen
damit wir auch sehen mit welchem
prozenten wir für oder dagegen sind
danke
damit kann habe auch niemand sehen wer
wie abgestimmt
wird also es ist eine geheime abstimmung
die man sieht wer
verhalten hat darstellungen
elektronische abstimmung immer dann wenn
es explizit beantragt und beschlossen
ist oder wenn wir es hier nicht sehen
nicht mit bloßem auge eindeutig erkennen
können in der regel wenn wir halt hier
oder wenn wir unterschiedliche
auffassungen präsidium haben dann machen
wir es automatisch von hier oben
verfahrenszeiten elektronisch ansonsten
wird als standard fall offen abgestimmt
so gibt es eine gegenrede zur abstimmung
zur elektronischen abstimmung
ist nicht der fall dann kommen wir zur
abstimmung auf eine abstimmung über die
frage ob elektronisch abstimmen wenn sie
elektronisch abstimmen möchten wir jetzt
die baustellen karte
ja ich gehe mal davon aus dass das eine
deutliche mehrheit ist
enthaltung ist das ein deutlicher
mehrheit großer mehrheit so beschlossen
dann stimmen wie elektronisch ab dann
bitte ich eine folie vorzubereiten
abstimmung über den antrag sn 10
sie sehen das nochmal eingeblendet ich
eingeklemmt vor 1 jahr 293 diesen alltag
stimmungs gegen darin dass der bundestag
beschließen möge dass die gewerkschaft
zentrum die frühjahr zentrum automobile
hieß von der unvereinbarkeit liste
entfernt wird dort steht sie seit
oktober
21 laut beschluss des bundesvorstandes
drin und darauf die unvereinbarkeit
liste entscheidet ja über die frage
welche nicht organisationen wollen wir
mit uns zusammen seite an seite
politisch haben und welche nicht
die geräte sind im übrigen 10 53
akkreditiert
und sie haben noch zehn sekunden zeit
für
ihre abstimmung zehn sekunden in denen
sich die partei eben politisch zwar in
einem kleinen themenfeld bewegt aber
bundespolitisch von großer bedeutung
schließen ein ergebnis einzubinden
[Applaus]
damit hat die partei beschlossen dass
diese zentrums automobil vor einem von
der unvereinbarkeit ist nicht sehr
gestrichen wird ein weiterer sieg für
erkenne ich muss nicht mehr abgestimmt
werden wir haben noch eine wortmeldung
aber eigentlich gar keine debatte kann
nur ein verfahrens antrag oder
dergleichen sein herz ja vor der
abstimmung hat sich hier ein vorfall
verregnet und zwar außerhalb des
bereichs des präsidiums die frau
kollegin dr weide hat einen delegierten
aus baden württemberg zweimal die geste
mit dem finger an die stirn klopfen
gezeigt du spinnst so etwas ist
gemeinhin strafbar als vergehender
beleidigungen da zum glück nur auf
antrag verfolgt
jedenfalls eines bundes sprechers
unwürdig und ich versuche das präsidium
hierfür einen ordnungsruf zu erteilen
danke
ja also ich glaube die lippen haben
gesagt ich mach es nochmal
das bild das wir gerade von alice
weitersehen offensichtlich wenn es sich
denn zugetragen hat zugetragen das
müssen sie bitte über andere wege klären
das können wir hier von hier aus und
können und wollen wir von hier aus
nicht ruhen lassen wir uns zur
sacharbeit zurückkehren
der tagesordnungspunkt 14 ist damit
fertig bearbeitet
wir
rufen dann jetzt beschluss gemäß auf den
top 15 und
lassen ihn geöffnet verlassen ihnen
sogleich wieder er bleibt also offen den
top-16 den rufe ich
aufrufe keinen antrag auf und verlassen
der bank ebenfalls geöffnet der top 17
radtour beschlussfassung im änderung der
bundessatzung sind aufgerufen
ebenfalls ohne wird geöffnet
aktuell kein antrag aufgerufen bleibt
offen und willkommen zum
tagesordnungspunkt 18 beratung und
beschlussfassung über änderungen an der
schiedsgerichtsordnung
so das ist jetzt ein antrag in dem die
partei sich unter anderem mit sich
selbst
beschäftigt schiedsgerichtsordnung sie
kennen das ja landes und bundes
schiedsgericht entscheiden über ein
parteiausschlussverfahren über partei
und gegen einzelne mitglieder gebe ich
jetzt für diesen top 18 an den kollegen
weiter
so meine damen und herren wir beraten
jetzt anträge zur schiedsgerichtsordnung
und beginnen mit dem antrag spo2 auf
seite 51 des antrags buches
antragsteller ist der bundesvorstand
wird seitens des bundesvorstandes das
wort zur begründung gewünscht da geht es
um die förderung zeitnah schiedsgerichts
urteile durch verweisung und andere
landes schiedsgerichte in diesem antrag
zur bundessatzung ist über die
schiedsgerichtsordnung dr wolff
offensichtlich
ein moment ich muss mal kurz den
sitzplatz wechseln
weil nur hier kann ich die mikrofone
freischalten herr dr wolff bitteschön
genau schönen guten morgen auch von mir
ich bin beauftragt vom
bundesvorstand dem alten bundesvorstand
der diese beschlüsse vor diese anträge
vorbereitet und im übrigen einstimmig
beschlossen hat hier vorzutragen und
möchte gleichzeitig erstmal
grundsätzlich
einführen schiedsgerichtsordnung
ganz wesentlicher punkt es wurde schon
angesprochen von alice beide gestern es
ist ein ganz wesentlicher punkt für das
funktionieren und für den rechtsfrieden
und unserer partei auch für das
erwachsenwerden unserer partei dass die
schiedsverfahren möglichst
reibungslos und auch möglichst zügig
durchgeführt werden wir müssen leider
feststellen dass an einzelnen stellen in
einzelnen schiedsgerichten
verfahrensdauern von zum teil mehreren
jahren gang und gäbe sind der antrag
spo2 dient dazu hier abhilfe zu schaffen
denn es ist für die partei von hohem
interesse dass rechtliche
fragestellungen so rasch wie möglich
geklärt werden
anhängige verfahren die sehr
unterschiedlich bislang bearbeitet
werden
zum teil verzögerungen von immer wieder
monaten es gibt einzelne verfahren die
wirklich jahre lang dauern das ist
unbefriedigend für die mitglieder dass
es unbefriedigend für die gremien die
oft nicht klar wissen können wer nun
entscheidungsbefugt ist und wie deswegen
soll innerhalb eines überschaubaren
zeitraums klarheit geschafft werden die
gerichte sollen verpflichtet werden
die ihnen vorliegenden verfahren in
angemessener zeit zu
fördern
eine förderung liegt dann nicht vor wenn
weder das gericht noch eine der
verfahrensbeteiligten parteien ein
fortgang des verfahrens
betreibt wir haben das mit einem sechs
monats zeitraum
konkretisiert die verfahren müssen so
vorangetrieben werden das kann
vollständiger stillstand eintritt in
diesen fällen soll das verfahren an ein
anderes schiedsgericht verwiesen werden
können dadurch soll die
schiedsgerichtsbarkeit unterstützt
werden zeitnah urteile zu fällen zu
diesem ausgangs antrag gibt es in der
diskussion nach aufnahme in das antrags
buch gab es konkretisierungen und
anregungen auf der cisco sagte dr wolff
ich würde dann an dieser stelle den
antrag es geo 2.1 einblenden also die
neufassung wenn ihr jetzt bitte darum
muss machen kann
bitteschön
genau es gab dankenswerterweise eine
reihe von hinweisen aus kreisen der
satzung juristen des satzungs ausschuss
ist der antragskommission ja und während
sich die partei in der präzisen
formulierung von änderungen in ihrer
eigene struktur gegeben hat ist das
geschehen zu beginn dieses parteitags
grund genug um dies zu analysieren und
wie das bewertet wird das kann uns jetzt
alexander keller mit gästen erzählen ja
das war natürlich hoch spannend was da
gerade abgelaufen ist und sehr präzise
und wegmann für eine mögliche neue afd
die wir auf diesem parteitag erlebten
und für die analyse begrüße ich angreife
müller vom spiegel und alexander kissler
von der neuen zürcher zeitung jahren
jetzt gab es gerade eine abstimmung über
eine unvereinbarkeit mit einer
organisation bisher weiß unvereinbare
jetzt diese gestrichen worden diese
unvereinbarkeit also jetzt zulässig die
kontakte die rechtsextremistische
tendenzen hat die mit rechtsrock bands
verbunden ist 60 prozent haben blöcke
recht gegeben der hier massiv dafür
geworben hat diese organisation von der
unvereinbarkeit liste zu streichen
und zwar mit dem argument wir schaffen
unsere eigenen werte unseren eigenen
rechtsstaat und praktisch unsere eigene
verfassung wir lassen uns
verfassungsschutz nicht vor beschreiben
die in deutschland rechtsstaat
demokratische rechtsstaat abläuft das
wurde mit großem applaus quittiert und
60 prozent haben sich dieser position
angeschlossen das heißt die afd baut ihr
eigenes wertegerüst innerhalb der
bundesrepublik war sie als staat im
staat sie sagt auf jeden fall dass sie
selber definieren will wer
rechtsextremist ist in diesem land und
nach ihrer definition bei leben quasi
keiner mehr und sagt eben auch dass
diese rechtsextreme gewerkschaft die
glaube ich nicht nur tendenzen hat
sondern einfach so ist dass die eben nun
bei ihnen mitglied werden kann und
sperren tatsächlich sehr weit aus
geführt er hat auch gesagt es für das
umfeld ist für eigene medien usw also
das war ein sehr starkes plädoyer von
ihnen dafür sich selbst zu definieren
und 60 prozent dass herr kessler ist die
afd raus und damit den boden der
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
zu verlassen ja das ist ein sehr
weitreichendes er muss natürlich noch
abwarten heute ich würde es auf grund
dieses stimmungs ergebnisses da ist
nicht komplett den strich drunter
anziehen aber klar ist natürlich dass
sind klarer sieg für das öko lager er
hat dafür geworben dann sinkt auch die
gestern behauptete harmonie innerhalb
des vorstandes ist bei solchen punkt nur
illusion herr jung ist also stark in die
vorlage gang hat gesagt du denkst nicht
politisch drücke machst das geschäft des
verfassungsschutzes hat die mehr hier
nicht überzeugt hingegen hat gesagt was
der verfassungsschutz wenn wir dann
irgendwelche paar stimmen abgrasen
können können wir uns mit denen auch
zusammen ins boot setzt man versucht
eine trendlinie zu sehen zu ziehen
zwischen den rechtsradikalen vorstands
leuten und den mitgliedern und das große
thema was ja immer wieder genannt wenn
hier was auch umstritten ist wie weit
sind wir eine vorfeldorganisation die
auch den protest auf der straße und das
kulturelle vorfeld aufnimmt und hüppe
und andere blockieren für eine
sogenannte bewegungs partei die als
gewissermaßen der parlamentarische arm
auch radikaler bewegungen auf der straße
ist und der themen ist einen einen
klaren sieg errungen und man sieht es
schon an der auseinandersetzung zwischen
den beiden vorstandsmitgliedern baum und
jungen im vorstand dass eben diese
harmonie sich nicht verordnen lässt dass
ich schon am 11 einen tag nach einem
neuen angeblich hegemonial oder
monokulturell besetzten vorstand sich
große risse auftun man muss aber ganz
klar sagen dass der junge in dem neuen
vorstand in der wahnsinnig klein unter
pfad ist und eigentlich eine sonderrolle
hat und deswegen würde ich ihre frage
begegnen sie sich im weg von der
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
auf jeden fall mit ja beantworten weil
wir eben sehen und das war ja auch immer
die frage des verfassungsschutzes wann
kann man die wii einordnen wenn es eben
diese mehrheit gibt und diese mehrheit
gab es gerade ganz klar mit denke die
zuschauer in die wir zuschauer ich ganz
kurz noch ein einschub eigentlich müsste
jetzt eine pressekonferenz laufen tino
costa und alice weiter auf unbestimmte
zeit verschoben möglicherweise hat das
auch etwas damit zu tun dass alles
weiter angeblich einem delegierten aus
im landesverband den vogel gezeigt hat
was wir zu einer gewissen aufregung
geführt hat aber gut die afg ist ein
gieriger haufen wie man immer noch sagen
kann möglicherweise sie haben gerade
angesprochen alexander kissler
markierungen hat er dagegen geredet er
hat
auch texte dieser rockband zitiert die
da in diesen in dieser gewerkschaft
zentrum automobil auch aktiv ist oder
bzw gibt es enge verbindungen der chef
aber in dieser rockband gewesen zitiert
also dass in einem raum dass migranten
als gesocks bezeichnet werden und hat
das ja das können wir eigentlich nicht
zulassen wir machen in der
öffentlichkeit angreifbar und machen uns
letztendlich lächerlich wegen unserer
rechtsstaatlichen beteuerungen aber was
ist dann von diesen rechtsstaatlichen
beteuerung noch zu halten wenn 60
prozent die andere position haben und
mit diesen unsäglichen text nichts den
jedenfalls nicht schlimm finden ja mit
solchen extremen unappetitlichen texten
positionen kein problem hat er kann
natürlich schlecht einher des
rechtsstaates sein ist doch völlig klar
insofern ist eben dieser impuls der
immer wieder zu beobachten ist bei der
afg das hat auch die nach wie vor zu
treffende beschreibung jährigen haufen
die eben dazu fühlt sich in einer system
opposition einzurichten nach dem motto
wenn der verfassungsschutz dies jene
sagt oder wenn andere sagen das sei so
schlimm zu radikal zu extremistisch dann
entlassen wir dass das von denen nicht
vorschreiben dann entwickeln wir so eine
sehr unfair thiele unreife rechtsstaat
kritische trotzhaltung aus prinzip damit
zerstört man dazu nicht alle reden die
man teilweise gehört hatte man wolle
eine bürgerlich liberal gesinnte mitte
adressieren also die personellen
niederlagen gestern setzten sich bisher
heute fort in thematisch
programmatischen niederlagen für das
ehemalige model burger
es gab so lustige moment vorhin weil
ausgerechnet hans thomas till schneider
der auch schon seit jahren vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet wird weil
er ganz klar flügel obmann war weil er
eben nichts extremes sagt es ist schon
gut wenn wir uns von rechtsextremen
distanzieren aber wir dürfen uns nicht
von den distanzieren die sich nicht von
rechtsextremen distanzieren und hat sich
damit natürlich auch selbst als
rechtsextrem erklärt schon lustig
gewesen die haben heute wieder vom
sogenannten verfassungsschutz gesprochen
das sei ein
inlandsgeheimdienst der eines
demokratischen rechtsstaats unwürdig ist
uns ist der verfassungsschutz ganze da
die verfassung zu schützen damit den
demokratischen rechtsstaat
er ist nicht nur notwendig also er es
nicht nur gerechtfertigt sondern auch
absolut notwendig er schützt ja auch
diejenigen afg mitglieder
die geht
natürlich gerade bevor ich jetzt weiter
rede dass alles weiter am podium steht
[Musik]
die maschinerie zum rausschmiss von
mitglieder soll geölt werden hier soll
die guillotine
ganz kurz die ereignisse sind ein wenig
lukrativ heute morgen eine
pressekonferenz der kollege april hatte
und gerade steht alles weiter am
mikrofon und wir werden mit sicherheit
jetzt gleich rüber geben aber
einstweilen erstmal in der debatte über
die schiedsgerichtsordnung weiter und im
laufe dieser debatte wird alice war die
mit sicherheit eingreifen
vorschlagen ist keine lösung vom
grundsätzlichen her man kann ich den
richter einfach auswechseln und es
öffnet tür und tor für manipulationen es
öffnet türen tor dass solche verweisung
dann auffliegen weil sie natürlich
beliebig manipulieren können wenn ihn
der richter nicht passt dann wird er
können auch die parteien dazu beitragen
mit in allen möglichen an tragen dass es
verschoben wird es ist wirklich keine
lösung und es geht grundsätzlich nicht
dass man den richter auswechselt in dem
eine andere instanz diese art aktiver
anders hin gibt das geht nur bei
zulässigen verweisungen es ist hier
wirklich keine lösung und ich sehe mit
schrecken wenn in dieser weise verfahren
wird dann kommen ganz neue probleme was
heißt angemessen wann ist liegen die
voraussetzungen vor es öffne tür und tor
für neue überprüfungen auch für die
ordentliche gerichtsbarkeit dass solche
verweisung auf fliegen weil die ihm der
geräte die der vorgesehenen richter der
gesetzlichen richter hier letztlich
beiseite geschoben wurden ich kann nur
dringend davor warnen lassen uns zügig
weitermachen dieser punkt hat eigentlich
das format der nichtbefassung
vielen dank für fahren fort am
rednerpult
ja ich möchte darum bitten in dieser
gesamte debatte mehr sachlichkeit hinein
zu bringen und die emotionen raus zu
nehmen
denn es geht hier um eines es geht um
eines und zwar
ein instrument an der hand zu haben wenn
ein schiedsgericht nicht arbeitet wenn
verfahren monatelang jahrelang liegen
bleiben aus welchen gründen auch immer
dass das weiter verwies wird an ein
funktionales schiedsgericht wenn ein
schiedsgericht was definitiv bei uns in
der partei so ist teilweise
dysfunktional arbeit wir haben
dysfunktional arbeitende schiedsgerichte
wo die verfahren monatelang jahrelang
liegen und nicht bearbeitet werden und
darum ist es wichtig dort als parameter
auf der zeitachse zu haben dass nach
einer gewissen zeit verfahren
weitergegeben werden ich halte das für
einen immanenten bestandteil unserer
schiedsgerichtsordnung für funktionale
schiedsgerichte vielen dank
vielen dank wir haben einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag am roten sein
mikrofon
vielen dank christian krieglmeier ist
von sachsen gut möchte jetzt sind wir
wieder zurück am set liebe zuschauer in
liebe zuschauer nach dieser kurzen
intervention von alice sei die die
allerdings mit dem thema das wir
besprochen hatten oder auch ihrem
angeblichen vogel zeiten nichts zu tun
hatte sondern wieder
schiedsgerichtsordnung bei uns nach wie
vor an cup den müller und alexander
kissler ich wiederhole noch mal die
frage von müller die ich gerade nicht
zuende stellen konnte björn rücker hat
hier über den verfassungsschutz
hergezogen nicht nur in frage gestellt
absurdum führen wollen so genannter
verfassungsschutz obwohl der verfassung
geschützt werden soll der demokratische
rechtsstaat eben kein
inlandsgeheimdienst der demokratie
attackiert
der verfassungsschutz schütt oder der
die verfassung schützt ja auch unter
anderem afd mitglieder wenn sie sich an
die verfassung halten wie es diese
attacke zu sehen von von höcker jetzt
auch im zusammenhang mit der abstimmung
gerade über diese unvereinbarkeit aber
nicht unvereinbarkeit mit einer doch
rechtsextremistischen organisation also
diese formulierung des sogenannten
verfassungsschutz das macht schon länger
auf andere aus seinem umfeld um eben den
verfassungsschutz zu diffamieren und das
so zu sehen dass es eigentlich kein
instrument ist um die verfassung zu
schützen und es eigentlich konsequent
dass er das jetzt hier auf der großen
bühne auf sagt warum sollte er sich auch
vorstellen er sagt dass auch sonst in
alle mikrofone die ihm so hingehalten
werden und von daher ist es jetzt
wirklich der versuch auch noch mal die
leute hier davon zu überzeugen ihm auf
seinem weg zu folgen der
verfassungsschutz beobachtungen zur
vollständigen führen dürfte aber dass
sie davor keine angst haben sollen weil
sie jetzt eben selber definieren
ist das allgemeingut inzwischen der afg
ebenfalls bei einer mehrheit die der
verfassungsschutz als feind organisation
nicht als schutzherr der freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung gehen den
meisten
mitglieder mit dass sie da letztendlich
ja auch dann irgendwann mal aufs
grundgesetz pfeifen naja das ist wer
fragen hat der zukunft stellen ob die
meisten mit gehen also also viele sind
zumindest sehr kritisch eingestellt
gegen den verfassungsschutz und es ist
ja in einer demokratie auch nicht
verboten verfassungsschutz und
kritisieren das ist klar was verboten
ist extremistisch zu handeln straftaten
aufzurufen zu legitimieren et cetera pp
und ob diese grenze weiterhin
eingehalten werden wird das muss man
eben sehen wir sehen jetzt eben ein sieg
des zirkus' lagers nach dem anderen
insofern wird man schauen ob sich diese
kritik am verfassungsschutz die wenn sie
zivil ist natürlich legitim es sich in
eine radikale höhe aufschwingt dass man
praktisch dann einen zweiten staat im
staat versucht zu etablieren dann wird
man sich ja wirklich aus allen diskursen
raus schießen und und das ist genau die
frage die jetzt da ist ob man weiterhin
menschen ab stößt auch von vielen
parteiaustritten die rede die in diese
hoffnung haben dass sie war losungen
stimmen dass man sich als grundgesetz
partei versteht es war die losung es war
die kampagne wir sind die partei des
grundgesetzes oder ob man irgendwie sagt
ja wenn wir nicht gemacht werden dann
pfeifen wir auf alles dann können wir
uns auch alle restriktionen jetzt ab
sparen und versuchen gewissermaßen eine
parallelgesellschaft zu bilden ich halte
die frage für noch nicht entschieden
aber die tendenzen die wir heute haben
die deuten auf eine weitere verkapselung
in also eine weitere radikalisierung
auch der partei wenn man da kann man
jetzt eigentlich schon ein fazit des
freitags zu sehen was man schon vermutet
hat sich das jetzt bestätigt eine
radikalisierung eine entfernung vom rest
der gesellschaft
ja auf jeden fall also beziehungsweise
ich finde dieser parteitag habe gezeigt
dass die partei eben da steht wo es
viele beobachter auch schon gesagt haben
und dass jetzt dieses fein blatt von
einem jagen wollten der sozusagen wenn
dieses bürgerlich gesicht noch gemacht
hat für einen kleineren teil der partei
ist das eben weg ist also die sagen
selber die die sich gemäßigt nennen das
die maximal 30 prozent hinter sich haben
und das spiegelt dieser parteitag eben
wieder und damit ist halt die mehrheit
der parteien nun eine die zu recht vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet wird am
sonntag ist
thomas halten wann der präsident des
bundesamtes für verfassungsschutz
vermute ich mal wird morgen eine menge
zeit mit aktenstudium verbringen und mit
protokoll lesen seiner mitarbeiter die
den parteitag genau beobachten sie haben
gerade schon gesagt gerne provoziert ist
ja geradezu als verfassungsschutz objekt
beobachtet zu werden ja das heißt man
geht jetzt auf konfrontationskurs mit
den behörden so interessant dass er als
ehemaliger beamter gehörten eigentlich
dass die kompetenz für recht und gesetz
abspricht es werde schon noch diskutiert
mit bisher 1 einschlägigen ergebnissen
da haben sie natürlich recht wenn man
sich hier unterhält mit dem noch
vorhandenen die sag mal bürgerlicheren
gemäßigteren lagern ist das natürlich
ein drittel da haben sie recht ungefähr
ein drittel 40 prozent die sind
natürlich auch einsetzt man hört schon
von leuten die sich überlegen
auszutreten die frage wie sollen wir
jetzt diese beschlüsse vor ort also vor
allem in westlichen kreisverbänden
kommunizieren also müssen wir uns
demnächst für höhere plakatieren
sozusagen weil das tableau nur von
hückeswagen sich hat realisieren lassen
also man geht hier wirklich momentan
muss ich sagen einige entscheidungen
stehen noch an einen einen sehr
riskanten weg also das machtzentrum ist
jetzt hier eindeutig der osten der
partei das ist ganz klar die anderen
sind noch geduldet aber ich habe den
eindruck viele würden ihnen keine träne
nachweinen wenn sie die partei verließ
wieder ins gespräch gebracht wurde ja
schon sagt vermehrten leuten gehört das
modell was damals neu aufgeworfen hat
was sehr geschadet hat einer formalen
trennung auch in einen ost und einen
west verband ist das zu erwarten ein
politischer brain drain also ein
ausstieg vieler sogenannter gemäßigter
jetzt vor allem nach diesen vorfällen
also mein eindruck war dass wäre nicht
mit diamanten gegangen ist eigentlich
schon verstanden hat in welcher partei
er noch ist und was auf sie zukommt wenn
mag natürlich sein dass ich einzelne
jetzt schon noch entscheiden dass das
jetzt so ein massenexodus gibt glaube
ich nicht weil sehr viele in der partei
die ich dazu befragt habe eben sagen wir
haben verstanden so was für die afg
kriegen wir so schnell nicht wieder
aufgebaut was so erfolgreich ist mit dem
so dann müsste sich neues logo einen
neuen namen alles aufbauen die gesamte
struktur das heißt es die die noch hier
sind haben sich mit vielem abgefunden
und auch die die gestern schon gemerkt
haben welcher vorstand gewählt wurde
haben dann auch nicht gesagt okay wir
gehen jetzt wir unterliegen hier bei
jeder und entscheidung sondern werden
schon auch ein bisschen einfluss nehmen
also mein eindruck ist dass man sich
eingenistet hat in dieser situation dass
man sich das jetzt erst mal anguckt und
es ist auch nur konsequent von roeckl
jetzt so gegen den verfassungsschutz zu
keilen weil man eben sagt wir werden wir
entgegen dem eh nicht mehr dann sollen
jetzt hat die gehen die wirklich angst
haben und das muss ich halt arrangieren
das heißt es würde jetzt so ein
konservativ bürgerliches aushängeschild
noch gegen so ein bisschen im wind
quietscht das was ist da zu erwarten
naja kleinwächter ist er ein kleiner
sieger des parteitags großen erfolg
relativ zielsicher jungen geben in die
offene feldschlacht mit herr nooke hat
sie verloren muss man gucken ob es noch
mal wagt wir stehen ja auch vor
landtagswahl niedersachsen können sie
aus dem landtag fliegen und dabei den
nachfolgenden wahlen hessen vielleicht
auch im nächsten jahr und ein ergebnis
es ist nicht diese diese parteitags ist
natürlich die östliche führung die jetzt
gewissermaßen durchmarschiert ist
innerlich oder regional östlich wird nun
auch mit den westlichen niederlagen nach
hause gehen also herr krupp aller kann
sich mehr sagen was er gestern in
ermüden der monotonie gesagt hat alles
daran dass der alte bundes vorteil nicht
daran gehindert meine tollen ideen
umzusetzen es ist jetzt sein
bundesvorstand es werden so sie kommen
sollten seine niederlagen sein und es
werden hier alle zwei jahre neue
vorstände gewählt vielleicht werden die
karten die bis dahin noch auf dem tisch
liegen zwei jahren neu gemischt dann
bedanke ich mich für die begleitung des
parteitags bei ann kathrin müller vom
spiegel und bei alexander kissler vom
109 zürcher zeitung dass sie dabei waren
die zuschauer der spannungs generator
der af ddr funktioniert in jedem fall da
ist man nie genau was in den nächsten
fünf minuten passiert das hat der
heutige sonntag vormittag wieder gezeigt
wie es jetzt weitergehen auf dem
parteitag mit doris müller ja vielen
dank von dieser analyse über die ersten
stunden des sonntäglichen parteitag das
hier in riesa zurück zu denen jetzt sich
befindlichen spiegelstrich debatten die
in jeder partei während eines vertrags
verhandelt werden wir sind in der frage
über den parteitag oder dass der
parteitag entscheidet wie die
berichtspflicht von den schiedsgerichten
geregelt werden kann da gibt es eine
änderung dass diese schiedsgerichte vor
neuwahlen dem bundesparteitag über die
tätigkeit berichten und jetzt ist die
frage in welchem zeitraum das
stattfinden soll das ist eine frage die
sozusagen eine interne parteistruktur
beschäftigt und man kann dieses jetzt
was hier zurzeit passiert über schreiben
mit dem titel die partei beschäftigt
sich jetzt erstmal intern mit sich
selber aber auch das gehört zu einer
berichterstattung über einen parteitag
dazu das wird in jeder anderen partei
genauso gehandelt dass man interne
debatten führt weil diese parteitage
eben auch dazu da sind um interne fragen
auf einer brighton notwendigen konsens
regelung zu verändern oder zu belassen
also zurzeit
verhandelt und berät die partei über
fragen zur schiedsgerichtsordnung in
ihren reihen bei den landes
schiedsrichtern und bei den bundes
schiedsrichtern sie wissen ja dass diese
schiedsgerichte einen einfluss und eine
entscheidung haben auch in anderen
parteien über die frage von
parteiaustritten
parteiordnungsverfahren und ähnliches
sie werden benannt und gewählt auch hier
wurden ja auf diesem parteitag diese
bundes schiedsrichter und die ersatz
schiedsrichter gewählt neue kamen dazu
und über die frage wie die
berichtspflicht sein soll entscheidet
hier der parteitag gerade
zurzeit gibt es kein redner weil
offensichtlich die debatte beendet ist
und wir über
diese frage jetzt
entscheiden
ja und in der spiegelstrich debatte sie
sehen gerade dass sich einige über die
screenshots und über die laptops beugen
gibt es gerade eine debatte mit ein
kompromiss der hier im hintergrund
gelaufen ist während wir eine erste
analyse über den beginn des parteitages
gezogen haben ein kompromiss in einer
spiegelstrich debatte über die frage wie
halten wir es wir von der afg ist bei
der einführung einer berichtspflicht für
schiedsgerichte da geht es glaube ich um
den zeitrahmen in dem dieses stattfinden
soll aber
die ruhe ist jetzt zur zeit sichtbar
dass der parteitag ist unterbrochen und
es gibt keinen redebeitrag das gibt mir
noch mal die gelegenheit um über den
weiteren verlauf dieses parteitages zu
berichten wir warten ja immer noch auf
die pressekonferenz des neuen vorstandes
die sollte um 11 uhr eigentlich
stattfinden
wir haben aber immer noch keine neue
zeitangabe es hieß nur dass sich diese
pressekonferenz auf unbestimmte zeit
verschiebt wenn ich den blick von meiner
position aus auf das präsidium und auf
den neuen bundesvorstand auf der bühne
richte sehe ich viele leere zwischen
und
weiteren verlauf soll es ja auch noch um
politische sachthemen geben aber
wir bilden genau das ab was diese partei
zurzeit macht nämlich über interne
parteistrukturen zu berichten und später
dann wird es noch um das thema europa
gehen und um die frage wie hält der
parteitag es über die zu den genauen
waffenlieferungen
jetzt geht es erstmal um
schwarzbrot arbeit wie einige sowas auch
nennen während eines parteitages
das tut der sitzungsausschluss wunderbar
dann
frage ich herrn schröder ob sie vor
diesem hintergrund ihren antrag sg 4.1
zurückziehen möchten das tun sie
hervorragend dann
meine damen und herren hatten wir die
debatte auch geschlossen wird noch im
übrigen aber zur neufassung dann jetzt
das wort gewünscht
das kann ich auch nicht erkennen dann
meine damen und herren würden wir jetzt
abstimmen über
den antrag sg u4 in der so durch sg 4.2
ergänzten fassung wer ist dafür der da
lautet dass die berichtspflicht nicht
nur den bundes parteitagen sondern da im
bildungskonvent und den
landesschatzmeister konferenzen über die
tätigkeit berichtet wird mit wenigen
stimmen und wenigen enthaltungen mit
einer sehr eindeutigen
zweidrittelmehrheit angenommen
so wir kommen dann jetzt zum antrag sg 5
antragsteller ist der bundesvorstand für
den bundesvorstand darf er dr wolff
begründen
bundesvorstand hallo
da geht es um die frage bessere und
systematischere bekanntmachung bzw
veröffentlichung von
schiedsgerichtsentscheidung weile streit
beendet und rechts klärend wirken
dafür ist es sinnvoll wenn die urteile
die ergangen sind nicht nur im stillen
kämmerchen archiviert werden sondern
dass sie auch bekanntgemacht werden
damit in geeignete anonymisierter form
unter wahrung der datenschutzrechtlichen
sachen usw das kennen wir aus den
staatlichen schiedsgerichten weil damit
für alle seiten dinge geklärt werden und
zum frieden in der partei beigetragen
wird weil weitere verfahren nicht
geführt werden wenn klar ist dass das
schon entschieden wurde man das
nachlesen kann in einer entscheidung
sammlung das gibt es bislang nicht
bislang ist und unser antrag bezieht
sich übrigens ganz kleines
redaktionelles versehen nicht auf § 7
sondern natürlich § 3
der schiedsgerichtsordnung dort heißt es
bislang ganz kurz und knapp das
schiedsgericht erstellt eine
vollständige anonymisierte fassung der
entscheidung und diese kann vom
schiedsgericht sowie dem bundes-
beziehungsweise landesvorstand partei
öffentlich gemacht werden es ist
berechtigt diese einzustellen wir nehmen
hier anregungen und nachfragen auf auch
arbeiten in der geschäftsstelle des
bundesschiedsgerichts und wollen das
systematisieren sie finden den
antragstext an der
wand auf der folie wonach die
entscheidungen
elektronisch systematisch archiviert
werden auch mit einer möglichkeit des
zugriffs durch nach stichworten
aufgebaute sammlung die landesgerichte
können das gleiche tun das
bundesschiedsgericht ist berechtigt die
entscheidungen vollständig oder auch
auszugsweise wenn das nötig und
angezeigt ist gerade wieder im hinblick
auf persönlichkeitsrechte partei
öffentlich zu machen wir nehmen dabei
noch eine anregung auf und haben die als
bundesvorstand auch sehr gerne
übernommen im absatz 6 dass es nicht
heißt den parteivorständen und landes
schiedsgerichten sondern in der
reihenfolge bekannt zu machen den partei
den landesgerichten den parteivorständen
und den satzungsbeschluss des konvents
um hier alle relevanten akteure die von
diesen rechts entscheidungen informiert
werden sollten wir bitten diese im
grunde
diesen antrag der der dem rechtsfrieden
dient und der vermeidung von
rechtsstreitigkeiten
durch veröffentlichung und
rechtsklarheit
möglichst mit großer mehrheit zustimmen
vielen dank
vielen dank wir blenden dann auch gerne
genau nochmal sg 5.1 das ist die
neufassung des bundesvorstandes ein und
hier ist wie gesagt die änderung dass
der satzungsbeschluss des konvents
ebenfalls in geeigneter weise der
zugriff auf die sammlung ermöglicht
werden soll und das habe ich auch
richtig verstanden dass petitum müsste
lauten der bundesparteitag möge paragraf
3 absatz 6 und 7 der gerichtsordnung
anpassen wichtig redaktionelles
wunderbar kissen wir sind raten auch zu
protokoll
damit da keine unklarheit besteht und zu
diesem antrag eröffne ich die aussprache
als erstes hatte sich herr rücke man
gemeldet am blauen sei
ja schön danke ich halte den sinnvoll
für den antrag für sehr sinnvoll und
bitte dann auch in dem zuzustimmen
allerdings hatten wir eben davon gehört
dass die gerichte sehr überlastet sind
und das ist natürlich eine weitere
aufgabe für gerichte und der
bundesvorstand sollte dann auch darüber
nachdenken ob da nicht eine weitere
arbeitsstelle geschaffen wird die das
bundesschiedsgericht dann entsprechend
unterstützt vielen dank für fahren fort
am roten saal mikrofon
vielen lang meine anmerkungen geht in
dieselbe richtung also der antrag ist
absolut wünschenswert aber wir haben
gestern schon gesehen dass ich kaum
leute für als boni schiedsrichter
bewerben und wenn die jetzt die aufgabe
auch noch machen sollen also das macht
den job nicht attraktiver vielen dank am
rednerpult
in der tat macht natürlich eine
entscheidungs sammlung etwas arbeit
allerdings muss die nicht zwingend von
den bundes schiedsrichtern persönlich
ausgeführt werden mittelfristig dürfte
sich dadurch auch eine erleichterung
insgesamt in der rechtsfindung wie herr
doktor wolf da schon auch ausgeführt
hatte ergeben wir haben als satzungs
ausschuss wird eine kleine anregung
gegeben die es erfreulicherweise
übernommen worden und empfehlen
eindeutig die annahme dass ein wichtiger
schritt auch dazu mehr rechtsfrieden
mehr rechtssicherheit auch und dient
auch insbesondere vermeidung von
verfahren wenn man weiß okay da ist
etwas schon mal identisch entschieden
worden dann muss ich vielleicht das
verfahren nicht auch noch anstrengen
wenn ich weiß dass ich mutmaßlich
unterlegen werde sein werde das
rechtsfragen geklärt sind die kleine
anekdote müssen sie mir gestatten ist
kommen bei mir noch heute gerade vor
einem vor zwei wochen wieder einen anruf
zu einer geschichte die vom
bundesschiedsgericht
2017 oder 18 entschieden wurde gehen und
§ 19 der bundessatzung das hat sich
einfach nach wie vor noch nicht überall
rumgesprochen und wenn eine solche
entscheidung eine ältere entscheidung zu
geltendem satzungsrecht besteht die auch
die auf abrufbar ist dann ist das
natürlich sehr sehr erleichternd für
alle die damit arbeiten müssen danke
vielen dank es gibt dann noch eine
wortmeldung im roten saal mikrofon ja
ich hoffe wir kommen zügig voran und
deshalb nur die anmerkung dass auch aus
der sicht der landesschiedsgericht diese
regelung hierfür die dauerhafte arbeit
transparenz und absolut zu begrüßen ist
vielen dank
wenn es keine weiteren wortmeldungen
gibt schließe ich die aussprache und
dann stimmen wir über den antrag
sg
5.1 ab der ist ihnen ja auch hier
eingeblendet für die annahme ist doch
hier eine zweidrittelmehrheit
erforderlich wer ist für die annahme
danke schön wäre es dagegen
wer enthält sich dann ist dies mit sehr
großer mehrheit und auch mit der
erforderlichen zwei drittel mehrheit
beschlossen wir kommen dann jetzt
zum antrag sg 6
mitteilungspflichten von
schiedsgerichten an alle
verfahrensbeteiligten
antragsteller ist der satzungs ausschuss
dessen vertreter erteile ich das wort
tief lag
ja meine damen und herren auch hier
etwas detailarbeit das ist bei
schiedsgerichts geschichten das war ein
so was ist auch hier wieder ein
wichtiges detail die praxis sieht
bisweilen momentan so aus dass ein
verfahren eingereicht wird und dann hört
man erst einmal eine weile nichts davon
und das ist natürlich ein zustand wo die
verfahrensbeteiligten gar nicht wissen
was ist jetzt passiert und zumindest die
erteilung dass das ding eingegangen ist
fristgerecht oder formgerecht und das
ist ein aktenzeichen hat das sollte
passieren und deshalb haben wir das hier
entsprechend konkretisiert dass wir
unter einleitung des verfahrens tragen
am 14 entsprechend die detailregelungen
unmissverständlich
hineinschreiben wollen und das gleich zu
gleich dann auch geprüft wird wie es
jetzt auch schon der fall sein soll ob
der antrag unzulässig offensichtlich
unbegründet er scheint weil auch dann
gibt es dort regeln schon heute könnten
bestimmte verfahren wesentlich schneller
erledigt werden oder dann vielleicht mit
entsprechenden hinweisen von den von der
klage seite vielleicht zurückgenommen
werden wenn
diese schritte immer eins zu eins so
abgearbeitet würden
jetzt weiteren wollen wir in einem
absatz immer platz zwei auch dass die
rücknahme eines antrags explizit einmal
festgestellt wird auch dort erfahrung
aus der praxis es gibt verfahren die
sind schon die die dürfte es gar nicht
mehr geben die haben sich vom prinzip
her erledigt es fehlt aber dieses letzte
stück papier die akte kann nicht
geschlossen werden und man muss dann
dort lange nachhaken als
verfahrensbeteiligter auch die
landesvorstände die kreisvorstände die
betroffen sind müssen können auf diese
art und weise stück weit entlastet
werden es also etwas mehr struktur in
der verfahrenseröffnung und im
verfahrensabschluss dankeschön wir
bitten um zustimmung
vielen dank herr flack ich frage er wie
in die debatte antreten ob es
änderungsanträge zu diesem antrag gibt
ist nicht der fall dann eröffne ich die
aussprache und am roten saal mikrofon
hat sich jemand zu wort gemeldet bitte
liebe kollegen ich möchte mal ganz
kurzen eindruck zu einem
landesschiedsgericht geben wie das
überhaupt arbeitet ich bin mitglied in
hessen ich glaube hier bestehen
weitgehend
irritation was ein landesschiedsgericht
leisten kann wir haben drei richter
davon ist einer volljurist wir haben
eine halbtagsstelle in der
geschäftsstelle das ist die situation da
geht ab und an auch mal jemand den
urlaub beide von den richtern und auch
der chef stellen mitarbeiter die hierfür
letzten endes zuständig sind deswegen
antrag ich zunächst einmal den passus
unverzüglich zu streichen denn wenn der
urlaub ist das schlicht nicht leistbar
und darüber hinaus können wir
keinen druck auf schiedsgerichte ausüben
weil kein nachwuchs da ist wir haben das
vorgestern gesehen auf landesebene ist
es noch sehr viel deutlicher es ist
nicht so dass die kandidaten schlange
stehen ich habe gerade einen nennen wir
es ruhig weil casting von mehreren
wochen durchgemacht und mir durchweg nur
absagen geholt das heißt lassen wir es
bitte auch bei dem was praktisch
umsetzbar ist danke vielen dank ich
weise darauf hin dass wenn sie eine
änderung anregen möchten sie dies bitte
als einen schriftlich fixierten
änderungsantrag auch ein reichen
ansonsten werden wir darüber nicht
abstimmen zu dem was sie gerade
vorgeschlagen haben am blauen sein
mikrofon
guten morgen rainer dollar vom
kreisverband oder-spree dem kollegen
möchte ich jetzt insofern kurz
widersprechen als dieses wort
unverzüglich schon nach der definition
aus dem www ohne schuldhafte verzögerung
bedeutet wenn also jemand im urlaub ist
und deswegen ist ein schriftverkehr die
staaten kann dann ist das also eine
änderung meiner meinung nach nicht
erforderlich dieser dieser antrag reiht
sich ein in die anträge die bei ihm
gehört haben meiner meinung nach soll
das hier zu einer professionalisierung
der schiedsgerichtsbarkeit führen was
unterstützungs wert ist ich schlüpfe
aber an an einen anderen vorredner zu
einem anderen tagesordnungspunkt zu
einem vorherigen tagesordnungspunkt dass
dann auch der sogenannte bei bau oder
der der geschäftsbank für die
landesschiedsgericht
geschaffen und auch für das
bundesschiedsgericht geschaffen werden
können müsste denn alles den
schiedsrichtern zu überlassen wäre etwas
mit
entsprechende atrium der tätigkeit nicht
verbunden vielen dank
für eine debatte über schiedsgerichte
und deren realität die von der
satzungsdebatte verein schließt wird
landesschiedsgericht mal zwei drei
wochen im urlaub ist darum geht es
hierbei nicht wir haben verfahren wo es
eben das ist mutmaßt sie dann nicht bei
ihnen das will ich ja gar nicht gesagt
haben in hessen wo verfahrensbeteiligte
das über monate nicht wissen dass ein
verfahren überhaupt anhängig ist da
reden wir nicht über wochen da geht es
um grundsätzliche rechtsstaatliche
prinzipien dass wenn ich verklagt werde
die klage anhängig ist als vorstand
beispielsweise dass ich dann auch
darüber kenntnis haben muss und zwar
zeitnah unverzüglich ist ein ausblick
baarer rechtsbegriff der natürlich in
einem schiedsgericht wo vielleicht gar
kein personal da ist auch etwas
großzügiger zu bewerten ist als in einem
schiedsgericht das sich vielleicht an
eine professionelle geschäftsstelle
halten kann wie es in den größeren
landesverbänden ja durchaus der fall ist
und in den kleineren verbänden sollten
im idealfall ich weiß dass nicht immer
der fall ist aber im idealfall auch die
anzahl der verfahren deutlich geringer
sein insofern
grundsätzliche rechtsstaatliche
prinzipien die leistbar sind die wir so
formuliert haben dass sie überall auch
geleistet werden können das ist nicht
viel arbeit das ist wirklich ein blatt
papier einmal das aktenzeichen einmal
zugeschickt das muss früher oder später
sowieso gemacht werden und wir halten
das für dringend erforderlich bitten um
zustimmung ohne streichung auch das wort
unverzüglich weil das wie gesagt kann
durch auslegung entsprechend schon dort
vernünftig gelöst werden die problematik
danke
vielen dank dann fahren wir fort am
roten saal mikrofon ja auch dieser
antrag erscheint mir vernünftig zu sein
die bedenken sie wirklich angebracht
wichtig ist ja tatsächlich das neu dass
der gegner stets vom verfahrens eingang
erfährt und das ist richtig so und das
unwort unverzüglich völlig unbedenklich
das heißt nach bgb legaldefinition ohne
schuldhaftes zögern und wenn man urlaub
ist dann kann man das nicht machen also
dass es völlig unbedenklich bitte auch
hier zustimmung und zügige dass wir
zügig vorankommen
vielen dank dann frage ich ob der
änderungs ob ein mittlerweile ein
änderungsantrag eingereicht wurde und
es möchte auch noch niemand einen
einreichen
gut dann beenden wir die debatte es
liegen auch keine änderungsanträge vor
wir kommen also zur abstimmung über den
antrag sg 6 sowie er im antrags buch
enthalten ist zur annahme ist eine
zwei-drittel-mehrheit erforderlich wer
ist für sg 6
überlässt natürlich die satzung danken
der partei deswegen eine
zweidrittelmehrheit
dann ist dies nahezu einstimmig
angenommen wurden
wir kommen dann jetzt zum antrag sg
sieben antragsteller ist der
bundesvorstand
herr doktor wolf für den antrag für den
bundesvorstand begründen da geht es bei
offenkundig unstreitigen sachverhalten
darauf dass eine mündliche verhandlung
ermöglicht wird das man darauf
verzichtet auf diese mündliche
verhandlung bislang hat der
schiedsgerichtsordnung in der
schiedsgerichtsordnung dass in jedem
fall eine mündliche verhandlung
durchzuführen ist das ist im
ausgangspunkt richtig aber ein es gibt
genügend fälle wo der sachverhalt so
klar ist das offenkundig durch eine
mündliche verhandlung nichts mehr
beizutragen ist und dann führt das
erfordernis dennoch eine mündliche
verhandlung durchzuführen zu einer
verzögerung zwangsläufig und in zeiten
wo es dann noch oft unter corona
bedingungen aber auch unabhängig davon
schwierig ist zusammenzukommen räume zu
finden und so weiter da
um dem abhilfe zu schaffen und im sinne
auch wiederum einer sinnvollen
beschleunigung im sinne einer erklärung
und rechtsfindung der antrag das auf
eine mündliche verhandlung dann
verzichtet werden kann und zwar nur und
dann werden der entscheidungserhebliche
sachverhalt unstreitig ist wenn also
beide seiten im grunde die fakten
übereinstimmend bestätigt haben wenn es
offenkundig ist so dass kein
vernünftiger zweifel da ist oder wenn es
ohnehin ausschließlich durch bild oder
tondokumente erwiesen werden kann die
vorliegen und wo auch durch einen
mündlichen beitrag der beteiligten vor
ort nichts weiter beigetragen werden
kann wohlgemerkt nur unter diesen engen
voraussetzungen soll das gelten wenn
diese voraussetzungen aber vorliegen
soll das schiedsgericht entscheiden
können ohne dann noch auf eine formel 1
ich bestehe aber auf einer mündlichen
verhandlung eingehen zu müssen weil das
in diesen eng umgrenzten fällen dann nur
einer im regelfall mehrmonatigen
verzögerung dient insofern im sinne
wiederum der beschleunigung und der
recht des rechtsfriedens unserer partei
für die schiedsgerichte auch zur
entlastung der schiedsgerichte die dafür
terminieren müssen und sich tage frei
halten müssen bitten wir um
unterstützung dieses antrags vielen dank
vielen dank ich eröffne die aussprache
wir beginnen am blauen sein mikrofon
ja dieser antrag ist natürlich
abzulehnen weil wer entscheidet
eigentlich über ein verfahren doch wohl
nicht das gericht sondern doch wohl die
parteien und wenn ein sachverhalt
unstreitig ist dann können die parteien
das unstreitig stellt und dann kann das
auf antrag geben wenn die parteien das
wollen kann die mündliche verhandlung
ausgeschlossen werden und nicht wenn das
gericht das für unstreitig offenkundig
hält das haben wir schon mal das wollen
wir nicht mehr und deswegen ist dieser
antrag abzulehnen
vielen dank wir machen weiter im roten
saal mikrofon
bitteschön
nordmeyer landesschiedsgericht sachsen
das recht das auf ein rechtliches gehör
als ein mündliches gehör vor einem
gericht das ist ein eminenter
bestandteil des rechtsstaates vor bis
vor 32 jahren hatten wir das nicht und
wir sollten dieses recht unbedingt
erhalten also der antwort ist einfach
abzulehnen danke
und dann hat das vorschlag
also die der folge der vorgetragene
lösungsweg dass wenn beide seiten sagen
wir wollen das nicht der ist nach
unserer aktuellen fassung der
schiedsgerichtsordnung eben nicht
problemlos zulässig es ist eben keinen
die chancen nicht rein dispositiv
insofern haben wir hier unter diesen
engen voraussetzungen mehrheitlich im
satzungs ausschuss zustimmung empfohlen
die
die frage die sich jemand stellt sich
aktuell auf beiden in beiden instanzen
typischerweise eine mündliche
verhandlung selbst dann wenn da nichts
mehr dazu kommt dann wenn etwas neues
entschieden werden muss dass neues
entscheidungserheblich ist dann muss das
natürlich dort seien dann muss ich das
bundesschiedsgericht und haben auch ein
eigenes bild machen wenn aber alles
unstrittig ist wenn keine zeugen
vernommen werden müssen wenn es nicht um
äußerungen dann ist das rechtliche gehör
auch auf anderem wege zu ermöglichen
nämlich beispielsweise im schriftlichen
verfahren das ist nicht ein verzicht ein
gleichgesetzt mit einem verzicht auf
rechtliches gehör wir empfehlen
zustimmen so weit der blick in die
debatte zur schiedsgerichtsordnung der
afg und wie hält sie es mit einzelnen
punkten das gibt uns aber gelegenheit
nochmal an set zu alexander keller zu
schalten der ein gast transnet hat ja
das ist ja auch dringend notwendig nach
diesem vormittag mit jemandem aus der
afg selbst zu sprechen und dass es
jürgen braun der
menschenrechtspolitische sprecher der
fdp-bundestagsfraktion herr braun gerade
gab es eine aufsehenerregende diskussion
um eine unvereinbarkeit mit einer
offensichtlich
rechtsextremistischen organisation die
mehrheit des parteitages
hat diese unvereinbarkeit nicht mehr
gesehen man kann mit dieser organisation
zu sagen jetzt kooperationen eingehen
ich vermute mal obwohl die gemäuer die
abstimmung geheim war dass sie das nicht
so gesehen haben dass sie weiterhin die
unvereinbarkeit sehen mit dieser
organisation
hat die afg sich jetzt hier einen tort
angetan indem sie diese organisation von
der unvereinbarkeit liste gestrichen
hatte ja also dieses thema hat eine
vorgeschichte im letzten jahr das ist
das problem dabei das thema wäre
geräuschlos und salomonisch sehr
vernünftig zu regeln gewesen
es gibt allerdings einen privatkrieg in
baden württemberg und der ist in den
bundesvorstand und dann noch in dem
bundeskonvent getragen worden und das
hat ergebnis haben wir jetzt hier auf
dem bundesparteitag
es ist so die organisation hat an der
spitze hochbelastete persönlichkeiten
wird nicht nur aber auch und die
organisation hat auch mehrere hundert
normale mitglieder die das als
gewerkschaft sehen als konkurrenz zum
auto ja sehen gewerkschaften vom
automobil heißt ja ja die sehen das
anders das heißt das thema ist durchaus
differenziert fall dass hunderte von
mitgliedern auch sind die völlig
unbelastet sind die sonst überhaupt in
ihrem leben wirklich völlige demokraten
durchgehend sind und dann meinetwegen
auch in der afg sind das ist halt der
punkt und diese differenzierung bei dem
thema die hat nicht funktioniert
das heißt ich habe mehrfach beim
bundeskonvent das thema angesprochen ich
bin mitglied des bundes konvents als
sogenannten kleinen parteitags bei uns
und ich wollte eine vernünftige lösung
damit es hier nicht beim bundesparteitag
behandelt wird so und das ist jetzt
genau passiert ist nämlich keine
vernünftige lösung offensichtliche
ausgekommen markierungen aus ihrem
landesverband hat der chef dieser
gewerkschafter offensichtlich mit gilt
eine rechtsrock band und dann geräumt in
einem lied
migranten und gesorgt hat auch gesagt
mit solchen leuten können wir uns ja
nicht gemein machen wir dagegengehalten
gesagt wir stellen ab jetzt unsere
eigene werteordnung unser eigenes
wertegerüst auf wir lassen uns von
niemandem mehr vorschreiben wie
rechtsstaat funktioniert und wie
werteordnung funktioniert
das habe ich so verstanden die afg und
die steht ja auch 60 prozent haben ja
für die position von heute stimmt bei
dieser abstimmung die afg steht nicht
mehr für die freiheitlich demokratische
grundordnung alter prägung und damit für
die bisher oder für die bundesrepublik
deutschland in ihrer heutigen form
gerade bzw hat ihr abgeschworen das ist
falsch das ist mancher keller bei allem
verständnis dafür dass dieses thema
kritisch ist und es ist aber auch ein
sehr schwieriges thema wie ich schon
sagte weil viele
automobilarbeiter oder auch ingenieure
fühlen sich nicht vertreten durch die
durchaus linksextrem angehauchte ig
metall die teilweise auch
linksextremismus gegen uns aktiv fördert
und die suche nach einer alternative
in bestimmten automobilwerken
unterbieten sich diese leute an und die
arbeitnehmer schauen nicht darauf was
der lebenslauf eines jeden funktionärs
ist das ist häufig der punkt aber
natürlich auch bei der diskussion gar
nicht es ging doch darum geht man mit
einer wie geht man mit einer option um
in der rechtsextremisten mit den ton
angeben diese basiert erklären ist ja
klar die wende auch wenn die mehrheit
oder ein großer teil dieser organisation
gar nicht rechtsextremistisch ist aber
man hat dieses jahr die idee hat das zum
rechtsextremistischen thema gemacht
das ist das ist in der tat eine eine
geschichte die die auch wie ich finde
sehr ungeschickt gelaufen ist sehr
ungeschickt und so können wir nicht
vorgehen wir haben keinerlei zweifel an
der dass wir auf dem boden der
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
stehen und die definition dazu gibt dazu
gibt es urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts was die
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
bedeutet und danach stehen wir als afd
bisher sehr viel deutlicher als viele
andere parteien in deutschland auf
diesem boden dieser freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung natürlich
lassen wir uns nicht vorschreiben die
definition vom bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz das bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz ist eigentlich
rechtlich gebunden und ist auch gebunden
an die definitionen die das
bundesverfassungsgericht dazu macht als
staatliche organisation jetzt kommt aber
zunehmend dazu dass das bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz eigenmächtig neue
definitionen erfindet wie zb sag jetzt
mal in anführungszeichen starts kritik
oder oder kritik an der regierung nein
kritik an der regierung ist erlaubt
kritik an der bundesregierung ist teil
der meinungsfreiheit und ist
selbstverständlich erlaubt
sondern es geht um rechtsextremistische
äußerungen von fdp mitgliedern das ist
etwas anderes als kritik an der
regierung ja gut aber die die
rechtsextremistische äußerungen
entschuldigung herr keller
im zentrum automobil sind nicht von fdp
mitgliedern gekommen es gibt keine afd
mitglieder im zentrum automobil die
rechtsextremistischen äußerungen gemacht
haben und auch keinerlei vergangenheit
dort gemeint ich jetzt auch nicht nur
dass gegen rechtsextremistische äußerung
von fdp- und außerhalb dieser
gewerkschaft die den verfassungsschutz
auf den plan gerufen haben und das
verwaltungsgericht in köln sie reden ja
von dem rechtsschutz auch für die afg
hat gesagt ja wollten partei ist ein
verdachtsfall für den verfassungsschutz
und sowohl die gerichte wie auch der
verfassungsschutz sind ja an recht und
gesetz gebunden in deutschland ist
gleich demokratische rechtsstaat das ist
die voraussetzung
das verwaltungsgericht köln hat
allerdings dem bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz einen breiten
beurteilungsspielraum eingeräumt was man
darunter fassen kann und es geht ja um
eine art beobachtung die beobachtung
heißt nicht dass es ein feststehendes
urteil ist auch nicht vom bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz und deswegen hat das
verwaltungsgericht gesagt okay ihr könnt
hier quasi probebohrungen vornehmen ihr
könnt gucken was ist ihr habt bestimmte
verdachtsmomente da geben wir euch sehr
viel freiheit das verwaltungsgericht hat
das sehr locker gehandhabt gegenüber dem
bundesamt für verfassungsschutz ich
würde das kritischer sehen aber das ist
eine rechtsansicht die eben sagt so eine
behörde wie das bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz eine politische
behörde hat diese möglichkeit so zu
agieren und dann muss man sehen
beobachtung prüfung heißt nicht
verfassungsfeindlich das ist etwas
völlig anderes gut dass werden wird man
ja sehen ist es in der tat jetzt es wird
gibt anhaltspunkte für
rechtsextremistische tendenzen das
nächste oder für rechtsextremismus das
nächste wäre dann gesicherte
rechtsextremistische einstellungen das
wird man abwarten müssen
soweit jürgen braun jetzt bei uns einen
schnellen interview auf dem parteitag
der fdp nicht dass sie da waren vielen
dank liebe zuschauer denn die zuschauer
ist es kurz vor zwölf uhr viele warten
jetzt auf den presseclub wir verlassen
jetzt den parteitag der afd der heute
vormittag zu mindestens eines gezeigt
hat dass in dieser partei offensichtlich
der hütte flügel immer stärker wird 60
prozent haben wir zugestimmt hat gesagt
hat wir wollen in zukunft unsere eigene
werteordnung unser eigenes wertegerüst
aufbauen das was bisher als werteordnung
wertegerüst und damit auch als
rechtsstaatlichkeit definiert worden ist
von anderen nicht von der afg von den
anderen parteien vom staat das ist nicht
mehr das was die kfd möchte sie will
offensichtlich auch eine andere
gesellschaft und im zusammenhang mit
dieser äußerung gab es dann an der
abstimmung in der afg 0 60% auch gesagt
haben ja wohl letztendlich hat gehören
höcke recht das wird sicherlich noch
weitere konsequenzen haben wir
verabschieden uns jetzt hier vom
parteitag presseclub kommt gleich im
anschluss und morgen um 9 uhr bei
phoenix das tagesgespräch mid mah jongg
markierungen einer von denjenigen die
hier wieder worte gegen bernd hecke
gefunden haben die gesagt um die afg ist
in diesem fall auf dem holzweg mit dem
werden wir morgen früh ein tagesgespräch
machen so weit jetzt hier aus dem
sächsischen riesa zurück ins phoenix
programm nachbarn bzw nach köln zum
presseclub
die reichste mensch der welt
geben jährlich über eine billion euro
für luxus aus